at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey everybody what's going on it's July
5th
hope everybody had a good Independence
Day and everyone still has all their
fingers
you know poor Pookie hit under the bed
all night yeah they were cutting them
off over here yeah we have because they
have their we have our own fireworks
like in this neighborhood yeah and uh
pookie was not having it like Tom even
tried to drag her out from under the bed
and show her like look it's okay and she
was just like no and she just like
jumped out she jumped out his arms and
like ran back out of the bed you should
see him from our back window I picked up
and said look at him and she's like
I thought she was gonna [__] scratch
me up then she ran back underneath the
bed and hid right under where I was
laying on the bed yeah she's directly
underneath Daddy yeah
good afternoon it's okay and she's man
so come on out man no yeah it's terrible
yeah and it was you know that all night
yeah I mean they kept going until I
don't remember because I fell asleep at
like 10 30 but yeah it was about 11 12.
yeah okay that must have been really
tired because they just were kind of
slowing down popping every now and then
yeah as long as they were popping she
was underneath the bed yeah she was
underneath the bed as soon as it got
dark and it started popping yeah
poor little girl yeah she knows what it
is she uh she she hates them
yeah she remembers she remembers okay
uh but yeah so how's everybody doing on
this Wednesday evening I see that some
people have already been commenting
about my lovely thumbnail for this it
has these two beautiful ladies
um
on the pictures I apologize for that
um that'd be Mary Percy on the left
there at Piercy and that uh is Amelia
Dyer on the right
neither of which uh they're not gonna be
winning a beauty contest let's let's say
it like that although there is something
kind of interesting we'll get into it in
a minute when we talk about Mary Piercy
but
um yeah that that picture of her that's
really the only one that I've ever seen
like I've seen another one online that
purports to be of her but to me it
doesn't look like the same woman like
that other picture of that supposedly of
her like actually looks like a normal
like decent looking woman but you know
what I mean what are you doing putting
you in into care no it's okay look look
oh all right
yeah well I just I just thought it was
like no it doesn't matter no that's it
see because look well yeah because I'm
not looking at that look at this she
wants to fight people I'm not fighting
I'm just saying this I'm looking at that
I know but usually it's just because
that's under there you know what I mean
like under the chat thing
but yeah so so I don't know if that
other picture is actually of her or not
because I find that hard to believe
although the in in the other picture
like her mouth is closed so maybe that's
because I kind of feel like that's
what's causing a lot of the um
uh aesthetic kind of um
I think that's what's causing that is
like the teeth but I don't know it is
like a kind of interesting uh thing
about that but like I said Jenny trying
to be a polite woman who's been dead for
a long time that's what made her look
ugly I wasn't no I wasn't trying to be
polite I was trying to be funny it's
funnier to me just like to say something
like that like you know butt butt ass
ugly well yeah but that's easy got a
[__] up Grill that's easy to say I
always like to come up with something
like kind of clever that's what I was
trying to do I don't give a [__] about I
mean she's a murderer I don't give a
[__] about being politics and she's and
she's been dead for more than 100 years
so it's like why the [__] would I care
about it I couldn't understand well yeah
you didn't understand it because I was
like I said I was just trying to make a
joke okay uh yeah
I'm a guy I don't have that sense of
humor no you don't no
um
Trey says Fourth of July Antics were
oddly calm in my neighborhood last night
yeah I mean it wasn't loud loud but I
mean it was pretty loud for like an hour
or so but then like the sun didn't go
down until almost nine o'clock so
um
Zach said meanwhile who took that
picture of Amelia and why is it so awful
yeah I mean that must have been taken
because when did she get caught I think
she was 56 when she got caught so that
must have been maybe that's her mug shot
I feel like because there's another
picture of Amelia Dyer too where she
doesn't look quite that bad and I she
looks like slightly younger though
because she was kind of caught more than
once you know what I mean
so I kind of feel like one was maybe an
earlier photo
and let me see uh yeah so I had to go
back to work today too so like a lot of
people did yeah Trey said it was all
over by 10 here people had to work today
though yeah I mean half people didn't
like show up but you know they didn't
show well no I mean I think some people
like taking today off or if they had
other [__] to do you know what I mean
and Tammy said one of the perks of
living in the middle of nowhere very
quiet here yeah it you know like I said
it was it wasn't too bad it was just
and they had mostly stopped by 10 10 30
because I was falling asleep by then
because by the way we watched uh Megan
last night yeah great foot uh and it was
well I guess we'll probably do a review
of it like this weekend or whatever
because I saw that it was on
Amazon Prime I think it was on Amazon
Prime
uh for free so I was like oh okay I
wanted to watch that I heard I saw an ad
today too for rentfield and I think it's
streaming on peacock but I've fallen for
that before where it the ad says it's
streaming on peacock but then you go on
peacock and it's like oh well you can
watch it but you have to like subscribe
to this other channel you know what I
mean so I don't know if it's actually
there or not but I'll check you know
um oh Zach says that that pic of Amelia
was her entry photo into the Asylum
according to Wikipedia yeah that was
another thing that she used to do was
like go into asylums all the time which
we'll get into in a little bit
um for various reasons I mean you could
probably guess what the reasons were but
yeah so uh so yeah so these two you want
to get into it you have anything else to
talk about okay
now do you know anything about either of
these two ladies I know about the one
that was uh throwing them babies at the
temps remember that one yeah the other
one no I don't I didn't know yeah I kind
of feel like it's you mentioned
something about it it didn't sound
familiar it's weird because a long time
ago
like I kind of put these two together I
think it was I think these two get
linked sometimes just because they were
two of the women because I don't know if
like anybody that know that um kind of
follows up about Jack the Ripper and
stuff and there's a theory I don't buy
it but um there's a theory called Jill
the ripper where you know people think
that maybe Jack the Ripper was a woman
um you know mostly because it seems like
oh well only a midwife could have like
walked around in the streets like
covered in blood and nobody would have
said boo to her but it's like I don't
know it's maybe there's other things but
that's going back like almost to when
the Jack the Ripper murders happened
like there were people thinking that it
was a woman and stuff but like I said I
don't buy it it seems like a very male
kind of crime but I'm not it's not
impossible but so both of these women
um have kind of been bandied about as
possible suspects for uh Jill the Ripper
as they call it now Amelia Dyer I doubt
it because her Mo was completely
completely different it um and it seems
like her
her motive was
um largely it seemed like at least at
first was and I know this is a terrible
thing to say but practical I mean she
was trying to make money I think she did
start to enjoy it
as time went on
um but I don't think that that was the
impetus for her getting into it I think
it was just kind of like monetary
concerns to start with Mary Piercy um
the murders she committed were very
brutal that's for sure but I don't know
necessarily if they were
premeditated or if it was just kind of
like a crime of passion kind of thing
you know what I mean so it's like I
don't really know if the motive is the
same as Jack the Ripper so I don't
really think that either of these two
are good candidates there is another
like weird thing that some people point
out about the Mary Percy Piercy case
um that but I don't know it's weird but
I think it's a reach so we'll get into
that in a little bit too you know what I
mean like but I think that's why these
two get lumped together a lot yeah all
that worried about who Jack the Ripper
was they came up with some crazy ass
ideas
there was definitely a dude yeah that's
like that's a very Dudley crime yeah and
he was just
had a way to get around and not being
noticed you know which
is not that's not that hard to do
to go around well especially back then
yeah you just planted he was just
wearing something that blood didn't show
up on it might have been a rain jacket
or something it could have been or
something that was the right color if it
got blood on he didn't see it some kind
of Overcoat maybe it was a reversible
who knows
yeah maybe he had it all [__] worked
out I'm sure oh yeah I'm sure it was a
plant yeah yeah he was like any other
typical serial killer that never got
caught you know a zodiac type dude
it's like that yeah they planned the
[__] I'm not saying I mean some of the
[__] that he did was Dumb and everything
like that but it's like it wasn't that
dumb because he never got caught he
never got caught it was he was a thrill
killer I think he he liked I think he
liked the fact that he could get caught
but was getting away with it yeah
Camp guy said people seem to be very
desperate just for food and shelter back
then back in the Victorian era don't
know if they were more or less so than
we are now I would imagine there's more
oversight now yeah and uh matter of fact
not and actually the Amelia Dyer case I
kind of feel like
um her case in particular was and I'm
not saying she wasn't like an evil
[__] because she was but
circumstances in society at that time
probably contributed to uh the framework
in which she operated which we'll get
into in a little bit and actually her
case and like other cases like hers she
was a baby farmer which we'll get into
what that is later but um there were a
lot of them and like some of them were
legit but a lot of them weren't because
there wasn't like you said any oversight
so
um her case and some other ones actually
led to like laws being changed yeah like
not too long after in this area in this
era I don't think they gave a [__] about
little kids and babies no they really
didn't seem to it's like ever well
especially if the babies were
illegitimate or working class like from
a working class family or something like
that yeah they didn't give a [__] about
poor people I mean obviously and some of
the laws they passed back then like I
was listening to a documentary and they
were talking about some of the laws like
I said that sort of directly or
indirectly like contributed to the
circumstances in which Amelia Dyer was
able to make a lot of money doing what
she was doing
but I get
I guess like from a Victorian mindset I
get like where the impetus for some of
these laws came from but wow did they
really not have the intended consequence
that they thought was gonna it was a
case of let them being like thinking
we're passing a law that's gonna like
encourage family values and it just kind
of like horribly blew up in their faces
you know what I mean that's that's just
a
that's the history of civilization right
there you just even the Romans said but
two thousand years ago was the soytonius
or who was it
he says you just couldn't you can't
legislate morality every time you start
legislating morality it backfires so
they did they were never successfully
just don't steal don't kill don't rape
that's that's probably don't cheat at
business
if you build something you're
responsible for it almost back to like
Code of Hammurabi that might work
but real advanced stuff man they'll
subvert it any law you pass you can
subvert it
well like I said we'll get into that
because that I found that really
interesting like the the context
in which some of this [__] was going on
not so much Mary piercy's thing because
hers just seemed like a like I said more
like a personal like a crime of passion
but Amelia dyer for sure
um and Amelia Dyer
it's crazy because I feel like
maybe a lot of people aren't that
familiar with her even though they're
not entirely sure how many babies she
killed but they're thinking by
conservative estimate 400 maybe maybe
more yeah
um she really she really only got well
because she would she uh did it for a
really long time it's not unreasonable
and according to witnesses that were
saying how many like babies were coming
in and out of her care and [__] like
that they extrapolated that over this
period of time that's like four or five
hundred yeah babies which is not it's
not which is not crazy it's just
happening at a time when abortion was
illegal and dangerous even if it was
legal it would have been dangerous back
then all medical procedures were yeah
because nobody washed their damn hands
so really yeah it was filthy so really
what she was doing is she was kind of
providing late very late term abortion I
mean kind of and given the mom the
mother kind of like uh some good vibes
about it you know what I mean like oh
yeah he's gonna you're gonna find him a
better you're gonna find her a better
home that type of [__] no you're gonna
kill that baby
yeah but um
there was no place to
no place to unload these babies they
were in demand for them they were
there's plenty of them
plenty of homeless kids running around
well that's what I'm saying during this
era it's just like it it's
it's really interesting to think that
it's like that baby Farmers made so much
money because there were so many yeah
illegitimate children and like orphans
and you know mothers that couldn't care
for them because they were poor and [__]
like that I mean they never ran out of
babies whatever happened and even if
those kids ended up in orphanages it was
bad those were like worse than prisons
well here was another thing that I did
sexual abuse and [__] that I didn't
realize but if a baby was illegitimate
they weren't allowed in an orphanage yes
so there was another you were just kind
of [__] dog like a stray dog yeah you
were [__] and they probably didn't
survive too many winners
no and you know it it sounds awful rough
but [__] like this is kind of happening
now it's certainly there's big homeless
encampments all around La and other
parts and [__] up north and you know
going out of control it was like that
you know
just that England was a much smaller
place imagine a lot of that happening in
one small area
just part of their culture and they just
didn't have the technology or the
the wealth and Society wasn't
well developed it was it was getting
better but it took a while you know well
like I said there was still very much a
stigma about poor people
too it's like no one really gave a [__]
if you had money nobody gave a [__]
about that he could starve in the street
nobody cared they were real realistic
when it came to human life they didn't
really kind of [__] um uh give it any
kind of unrealistic value they were just
like no we got lots of y'all [__]
y'all ain't worth a [__] that's just
that was just really the and I don't
think a little kid was worth anything
until they were maybe I don't know 12 13
old enough to work in a coal mine
so five yeah there wasn't they they had
lots of those they're just running
around
who knows what kind of horrible [__]
happened to those kids oh I'm sure
because there was you there were sexual
predators of all different kinds and uh
I imagine some of them came to [__]
miserable ends and we'd never know
yeah I mean all those I mean the the
history of all these people is just
completely lost it's a completely lost
because that was a time when some perv
could just walk out and offer some kid a
meal and take him back to the house they
could never seen again and maybe they
were kept for a long time and then done
away with in [__] gruesome ways there
were guys like that like you know outer
fish type dudes yeah this is an you know
Albert Fish wasn't too far away and H.H
homes I think it was about a little bit
after this time
but you know people were always bad just
because they were victorians and they
had a kind of a [__]
look to them they were looking wearing
suits and dresses that didn't make those
people really good uh they had they were
way worse than yeah they were they were
terrible yeah no they had upper class
people not everybody middle class people
more like middle class people kind of
probably had some of the best morals but
rich people did where the [__] they
wanted and poor people did where the
[__] they wanted they were both kind of
like criminals above and below you know
um
so there's no telling what happened to
those little kids
yeah and it was like probably like
becoming like panzeran
yeah I mean a lot of them yeah that's
what I mean because if even if they did
you know grow to adulthood which I'm
sure many of them did not they're how
are they how are they going to be a
normal person like after being treated
like that for their entire lives you
know what I mean it's just life life was
cheap yeah it was pretty short you know
what I mean yeah I don't think they made
it to 30 a lot of them probably not
because it would cause a lot of trouble
on their way out yeah well and the thing
about it too like I said the living
conditions were horrible yeah um winners
the winners were horrible they were all
drunks they were all like on lauding
them terrible terrible uh diets that too
terrible [__] nutrition so they were
small weak if you were born you were
small and weak you just too low protein
unless you were eating damp cockroaches
which is how you know they had
cockroaches in in England in this era
probably
go back it's too cold for might be too
cold I don't know I think there I think
has only live in New York because
there's a Subway in USA because it's
warm and warm pipes and tunnels and [__]
yeah if they didn't have all that they
probably wouldn't be able to live up
there yeah because they're very tropical
yeah they have to it has to be hot
but yeah so they they do uh do that yeah
uh Zach says
I need to stop looking at that pic of
Mary it's giving me the creep she looks
like one of those wax faces of World War
One injuries yeah I want to get into
this though because this is crazy this
is going to blow your mind it blew my
mind a little bit like I said because if
that picture is indeed of her and I
don't see any reason why it wouldn't be
so let's talk about Mary Piercy first
because that's kind of the less
complicated
story
this woman uh was born Mary Eleanor
wheeler she was born in 1866. now they
don't know a [__] ton about her
childhood
but now one thing that they do that I've
seen like a lot of other things that are
about her like report this from her
childhood and this is apparently not the
case
well can I yeah yeah
why do you keep distracting me I'm
trying to like get the [__] show down
that looks better
okay okay she's like I lost my plate
well you keep like I keep trying to talk
and you keep playing interrupting I'm
sorry like with [__] you know what I
mean I don't know why you do that I
thought you were right there what okay
never mind I don't know what you're
talking about
um watching you go down the notes but
yeah okay
so one thing that gets reported about
her a lot from her childhood that is
evidently not true
is that a lot of um different things
will report that her dad Thomas Wheeler
murdered a guy named Edward ansty and
got hanged for it like when she was
younger like I think she was like a kid
or a teenager or something like that now
this is apparently not true
uh there was a guy named Thomas Wheeler
and he was indeed hanged for murdering a
guy named Edward ANSI but it was
apparently not her dad it was like
another guy that had the same name
um so yeah but so if you see that
reported that is evidently not true like
her dad wasn't hanged or anything like
that not like it makes a huge amount of
difference but that is something that I
saw reported a lot about her childhood
and that is evidently not the case so
here's the crazy thing so you see that
picture there on the left of Mary Piercy
now um she was described I guess she was
quite Young when she got arrested like
after the murder she did she was only 24
years old and she was actually described
they said that she had beautiful hair
beautiful blue eyes and stuff like that
nobody said that she was a butterface
even though she is
um but the crazy thing about it is that
this chick despite looking like that
picture
um apparently had all kinds of male
admirers and most of them were like
middle class or like like shading toward
wealthy because she never had to work a
day in her life like she always had like
a a bunch of dudes going like sugar
daddies who would like pay her rent and
like do all this other kind of stuff and
she just apparent she had all kind of
like male admire look like that at that
time maybe not like I don't really know
what happened this is before she got out
of prison and I said before she went to
prisoner when she got out she didn't get
out of prison okay she went in at 24.
yeah she went in 24 and she got hanged
and she got hands
Amelia Dyer was the one that was in and
out because she was like much older but
Mary pierce piercing she was a teenager
I guess but that's the thing it's like I
don't know I mean yeah I think that um
she was maybe an alcoholic yeah so maybe
like by the time you know she had got to
that age like and photography of that of
that era [__] it was kind of like it
kind of you kind of looked like a corpse
anyway Trail wasn't a very Prismatic
photo you know yeah some of the people
back then looked like terrifying well
because they didn't have like you they
don't have like you know they didn't
have a quick flash well that too but
they didn't have like quick flash
cameras like you had to stand there like
really still for like a really long time
so like you couldn't smile or anything
like that yeah the image just didn't
look right what was those little exam
glass plates these different photograph
on it yeah the um what do they call
lithograph or no daguerreotype
daguerreotype that's what it was called
yeah you look like you look like a
corpse on those things
yeah not really I have seen some like
pictures of people from the Victorian
area that were good looking but
uh this woman was not one of them it
doesn't look lifelike yeah like I said
they all kind of look like
like statue waxy corpses or something
but yeah so uh so yeah she apparently
was quite the popular young lady
so like one guy she had this boyfriend
named Charles Creighton and he actually
like rented some like rooms for her I
don't know if it was like he didn't buy
her house or anything like that but she
apparently had kind of a nice uh place
in North London
and uh so he would pay and he would come
and see her every week and she like I
said she had two or three going at one
time and then she also had a boyfriend
named James Piercy and she that's where
she took the last name from he didn't
marry her or anything like that but she
took his name for whatever reason and
just kept it like the rest of her life
which wasn't very long spoiler alert
um but even after like he didn't see her
anymore after they broke up or whatever
so
um she also had this other boyfriend
like she was still seeing Mr Creighton
who was coming by once a week or
whatever but then she met this dude
named Mr Frank Hogg now he was um
apparently like he wasn't wealthy or
anything but he was pretty solidly
middle class he was a Furniture remover
she was impressed because this is
hilarious
um she was impressed because he had like
a printed business card which oh big
deal I guess was something that a lot of
people back then didn't have honestly
because they were like super expensive
or something she was like ooh look at
the Rockefeller over here
but um but yeah so they started going
out
and um so that yeah so they started
[__] and she would like he had a key
to her house
and she would like put a little light in
the window like whenever she was
available like whenever one of her other
gentleman callers wasn't over I guess
and so that he could just come over and
like open the door with his key
problem was like the two of them had
seen each other for a while
but then uh it turned out that Frank
Hogg was also knocking down this other
woman named Phoebe Styles and Phoebe
Styles what's the hooker's name that's a
damn porn star name Phoebe's dad
Phoebe Styles yeah um and he knocked
Phoebe up
so at this point he decides I guess
she's like three months pregnant and he
decides he's gonna do the right thing
and marry her because like I said this
is Victorian England uh unwed mothers
were really not looked kindly upon and
you really didn't have any options uh
you were kind of hosed you either kind
of went into prostitution or left the
baby out and like went to the work house
or whatever that was really the only two
options yeah yeah that's what I'm saying
so um so yeah so Frank is gonna marry
Phoebe because she's gonna have his baby
now uh so when the baby's born well the
crazy thing about this is that uh Mary
was so into Frank Hogg they still have
letters that she wrote to him because it
was all introduced at the trial and
stuff
but she was basically so into him that
she was like well okay well if you have
to marry Phoebe then okay but and I'll
even be friends with her but you still
have to like come and have sex with me
you know what I mean yeah like they have
to like share the dude right so um yeah
so she was willing to do that
so the baby is born the baby is also
named Phoebe which is very confusing but
they actually called the baby like um a
nickname which was Tiggy
now what ended up happening so this is
uh about 1890 like early 1890.
um her and Frank had gotten Phoebe now
her and Frank had gotten married in
November of 19 or 1888 rather
now what happened on this point I guess
at some point Mary and Phoebe were
actually
friends I don't know if
I don't know if Mary was actually just
pretending to be her friend or was
actually her friend and like some [__]
went horribly wrong or what I don't
really know what you know nobody knows
what the [__] she was thinking
but apparently they did kind of were
friends and like hung out or whatever
like the two of them
I don't know also if Phoebe knew that
mayor that Mary and Frank were still
banging because they were I don't know
if she knew that
so uh 1890 October 24th 1890.
Mary writes a little note like a little
invitation
to send to Phoebe's house and says hey
why don't you come to my house today for
tea
at 4 P.M like or at 3 30 p.m or whatever
it was
so I guess Phoebe and the baby
go over to Mary's house for tea like
because of the invitation
around four o'clock on that afternoon a
neighbor of Mary's heard
um glass breaking and screaming sounds
like coming from Mary's house
so she went over there to see what was
going on but she knocked at the door but
nobody answered
three hours later at 7 pm
a woman's body was found lying on the
sidewalk
um in a road called Crossfield Road
so the guy that found it he called the
cops obviously
the woman's laying there and he's like
at first he thought she was just like
drunk but he couldn't see her face
because it was covered with like a
sweater or like a piece of cloth or
something
so he calls the cops the cops come and
they peel away the sweater and the
woman's face is just all bloody and her
uh throat is slit like so deep that her
head was almost cut off
so they didn't know who this was at
first so they took her to the police
station and then the morgue and then
they found out that not only did she
have this that was she almost beheaded
but she also had a fractured skull like
it looked like somebody beating the [__]
out of her head also
um and she was also like her hands and
arms and stuff like that were all
bruised as though she'd been in like a
you know a confrontation and she tried
to like defend herself or whatever
they also determined that she had
probably not been killed where she was
found because there was a little bit of
blood there but not enough like you know
because of the injuries so like well she
must have been killed elsewhere and then
dumped there
so as I said the police didn't know who
this was
um but later on like not too far away
from the where the body was found
they actually found a pram uh you know
or a baby carriage in U.S terms with
some blood on it and that was about a
mile down the road so they thought that
was a little weird so they took back to
the took that back to the police station
as well
and then the next morning they found
another body a baby
and this baby had died from Suffocation
um was otherwise unharmed well unharmed
she was dead but you know what I mean
she had been suffocated but no other
violence
yeah no other violence had been done to
the body
what they thought later after they found
out who this was was that the baby had
either just been smothered like you know
after the mom killed was killed but
they're like also what could have
happened was that that was that Mary put
the baby in the baby carriage and then
put her mom's body on top of it so she
could like carry it and dump it
somewhere and then like the baby
suffocated then they're not really sure
how that happened
I doubt that
well we'll get to that yeah
so um okay so like I said they didn't
know who this was at first they didn't
know this was Phoebe
so Frank the husband he's like kind of
wigging out because Phoebe was supposed
to go and have tea with Mary and then
like never came back with the baby and
he just thought that was unusual so then
they saw
um the paper and it said hey we found
this woman's body in this baby's body
and we don't know who they are and so
he's like freaking out so him and his uh
sister
Clara they go to uh report Phoebe
missing
now Clara goes to Mary's house and said
hey do you know where Phoebe is and
Mary's like nope absolutely not I do not
know where that woman is no siree
so then her and Clara go to the morgue
together
to see if the body that they found is
Phoebe
and one of the things that made the
police suspect Mary initially was they
were like when she came into the morgue
like with her sister-in-law
um well it wasn't her sister-in-law but
it was Frank's sister
um they said she was acting real real
weird like she was acting like real
hysterical and she was fine until they
like showed them the um the injuries
that Phoebe had sustained and then she
started like freaking out and then she
started to insist that the body was not
Phoebe even though Clara said yeah that
absolutely is who that is but Barry was
just acting so weird that they like took
notice of it you know what I mean like
she was acting super hysterical
so they also while they were there the
cops also said hey um look at this uh
pram
and is this like do you recognize this
or whatever and Clara said yeah that was
Phoebe's you know baby carriage
now interestingly when the police were
kind of like investigating this whole
thing it came to light that one of
Mary's neighbors had seen Mary pushing
that baby carriage with something big
hanging out of it like and like at night
I don't know if it was that night but
there's like they saw it from kind of
like far away but it's like yeah they
couldn't tell what it was but it was
just like a big thing like hanging out
of the baby carriage and they thought
that was a little bit weird like just
walking down the street like that
now once they determined that this body
was Phoebe uh the husband Frank was
actually uh considered like the first
suspect because that's usually I mean
then and now
um that's usually the first person that
they suspect
now he they searched his house
and they found this key that didn't fit
any of the locks in the house and
they're like what the [__] is this key
and then he confessed oh well that's the
key to Mary's house me and her have been
[__]
um so yeah so he had to like confess to
the affair but he's like well yeah but I
didn't kill my wife though
so the police thought that like I said
Mary's Behavior at the morgue was very
strange so they're like maybe we should
interview this crazy [__] because with
something's going on there we're not
really entirely sure what it is
so they go to her house and search her
house
now Mary let's just put it this way is
not a criminal mastermind okay because
they go and search her house
they find blood stains and just like
blood spatter all over the kitchen
they find a carving knife with blood on
it and they find Blood on the fireplace
poker
um there were also two broken windows in
the kitchen which you know the neighbor
that corroborated like the neighbor's
story because she said she heard glass
breaking like at around that time
there was also a rug that had blood on
it that looked like Mary had at least
tried to clean that even though she
didn't look like she tried to clean
anything else so why the rug who knows
but yeah
and then while the police were searching
her house they're like Mary was acting
super weird they're like the whole time
that they were looking around the house
being like hey blood here blood there
blood everywhere she was like sitting at
the piano like playing the piano and
like singing really loud
like just the whole time and they're
just like what the [__] is up with this
crazy [__] and so they asked her they're
like well you know what is all this
Blood doing in your house ma'am and she
said that she'd been killing mice but
she chanted it over and over killing
mice killing mice and they're just like
great well she's losing her mind yeah
she's caught yeah it's pretty crazy
pretty crazy
so uh at this point wisely the
detectives like I think we need to
arrest this lady I mean clearly clearly
there's something the matter with her
so they arrested her and charged her
with two murders and then when they
searched her bodily they also found
blood on her clothes and they found like
her hands were all scratched up as
though she'd been in a struggle and most
damningly on one of her fingers they
found two wedding rings one of which
belonged to Phoebe what was she thinking
so yeah like I said not a criminal
mastermind as I said not not the
sharpest uh tool in the shed is what
we're saying
so yeah so they put her in custody and
uh they're gonna commit her for trial
right
now apparently while she was in custody
there was like a woman there like that
was guarding her like looking after her
or whatever and apparently
um Mary told this woman yeah um you know
Phoebe did come to tea that day and like
she said something that offended me and
we got into an argument and at which
point she kind of decided he's like oh
maybe I should shut up because that's
like not really making me look good yeah
um so she didn't say anymore
you know so I figured it happened yeah
he started fighting over him
well yeah I don't know what he looked
like but I'm sure he wasn't really
[__] right so uh so yeah so they put
her on trial now she enters a plea of
not guilty which how good luck yeah well
she's getting anything to lose yeah the
death penalty right yes because they
they absolutely did not [__] around back
then it's like you did [__] like that
they're like yep hang them and they'd
even wait that long and until 1907 I
think they didn't even have an appeals
process like if you got a death penalty
they're like tough [__] yeah pretty much
unless like afterward I think there was
kind of a stipulation that if afterward
you come up with some reason that like
you shouldn't kill them like oh they're
pregnant or whatever
um but there wasn't any appeal process
you got a death penalty you were you
were gonna hang yeah it was more Humane
to get it over with yeah they didn't
really leave them hanging out very long
because I yeah I think she ended up
getting hanged like three weeks after or
something like that yeah
nowadays that you're sitting there for
[__] 10 15 years think about it then
they kill you 20 years
but yeah we were fighting it it might
take 30 years here in the U.S it's
[__] ridiculous
yeah
um okay
okay so one of the things that um and I
think I brought this up earlier but one
of the things that they talked about
that the prosecution like hide against
her they're like well look we have all
these letters that Mary wrote to Phoebe
or Mary wrote to Frank rather saying
like how much she loved him and like she
never wanted him to leave and it's like
I'll even be friends with your wife if I
have to and blah blah
um so they were trying to establish that
obviously they were both fighting over
this dude and for whatever reason like
things came to a head that day now
they're not entirely sure and they still
aren't
whether the crime was premeditated like
I said or whether it was a crime of
passion now on the side of premeditation
they pointed out that they're like well
Mary did send an invitation
um to Phoebe to come to tea that day at
her house I don't know if she was
planning on killing her but they did say
that when they searched the house that
they were like there was um blinds or
like a dark fabric had been put over the
windows that weren't you know it wasn't
there before so it's like so that seems
to suggest that she was planning on
doing some [__] that she didn't want
some people to see well
she didn't play as cool as a cucumber
afterwards
this leads me to believe that I think it
was second just uh spur of the moment
yeah it does seem like that like he
wasn't mentally prepared for it it does
seem weird that um
that that that the dark fabric was over
the windows but something else that
might have been something else but it's
like I don't know well that's the thing
they're like well she sent an invitation
to her like to come to her house that
day but it's like I don't know how
often that was it's like I heard that
they you know they said that they were
friends so maybe it wasn't that unusual
for her to invite her over
but I mean if if that was the only time
that she did that then yeah that would
be super size yeah but you also would
wouldn't think that well I'll invite her
over and I'll kill her nobody will think
it was me no maybe she did think that
maybe she was that delusional yeah maybe
she's not deleted she couldn't she
wasn't playing it off afterwards
see
there was no yeah like I said well I
think that they got into an argument
over the dude she felt assaulted
and hit her with that damn poker
and then uh
she came too but they're fighting and
then she slashed her throat
and then she smothered the baby threw
the baby in The Carriage through her in
the carriage and tried to wheel it all
out yeah it just dumped it like yeah
down the road she's probably gonna jump
her further away but she fell out and
couldn't get her back in So then she was
like [__] it and then just kept going
with the damn buggy
yeah she went another mile I think yeah
went another mile to get away from it
because it fell out right yeah just la
la la yeah
baby and they're so [__] I get rid of
this baby and she got rid of all that
[__] and then walked back home
it's crazy to me that she didn't try to
clean up the house though because there
was still blood just everywhere yeah she
had not been very cleanly to begin with
maybe and didn't have a concept of that
didn't have any idea what forensics were
it's like she tried to clean the rug it
seemed like but the rest of the [__] not
so much probably probably pinched for
time because it wasn't planned so she
had to get rid of that body first and
she wasn't strong enough really to do it
and by the time she got back she was
bushed and [__] thought she got away
with it we were scared you know uh
cleaned up a little bit but then didn't
think about all the blood that she slung
around him from [__] hitting her with
a dab stick
the poker
because it was probably you know blood
splatter from swinging yeah because man
everywhere she didn't realize it was up
on the ceiling and the walls and stuff
she was probably thought she probably
just looked on the floor thinking that
blood just Falls
doesn't realize that she's [__]
flinging it on the walls in the ceiling
and [__] I mean that was kind of the
whole that that was Dexter's job on the
show and it may have been he was a
Bloods back Dirty by today's standards
so it's all just kind of Blended in I
feel like the Victorian era as a whole
was dirty but today
[Laughter]
everything was covered with [__] and
yeah stank and then like [__]
intestines and there was horse [__]
everywhere in downtown I think only real
rich neighborhoods they picked up
horseshit the rest of the rest of it
just let it pile up yeah and then it
would and then it's England so it rains
all the time so it was nice and slushy
yeah so probably like the bottom of all
your clothes like probably had poop on
them all the time throwing chamber pots
out the window yeah just disgusting
nasty [__] that's what I mean it's
like can you imagine how that smells
Jesus I would never want to go back to
that time but uh but yeah it wasn't any
kind of planning [__] urban planning
you started building houses up next to
each other yeah that's it they didn't
come until later everyone just kind of
piled everything just like well there's
space over here just put that in yeah
put it over there
it'll be all right they didn't they were
really thinking
they weren't really thinking anything
now they weren't putting water pipes or
anything no like I said I know everybody
I know I've recommended this book before
but there's one called the ghost map
that's really really good that's kind of
about London it's about that cholera
epidemic and how they figured out that
like drinking poop water like actually
gives you diseases who would have
thought right it's just [__]
it came out of you
it's natural as God attended
I sure probably some people did think
like that yeah
I mean it kind of makes sense if you say
it that way even though it's right yeah
there are people today that think that
it's unnatural to shower so you just
walk around stinking oh well you don't
have to shower you don't have to shower
you don't have to wipe your ass either
okay you're gonna have [__] you don't
have to but you're not get you're not
gonna have animals don't wipe your ass
so yeah they do they [__] drag your
[__] ass across the [__] grass and
[__] if they have to and then or just
lick it yeah but you know they got
[__] saliva that'll kill anything you
know [__] humans don't have that yeah
that's why they don't have toilet paper
yeah they don't need it yeah they passed
that test they have a [__] natural
selection
any any cat or dog that didn't have
[__] caustic saliva died from dirty
ass
ass to mouth disease right yeah oh my
God yeah so yeah
so like I said they're not really sure
if it was just like you said I kind of
feel like I'm leaning more toward it
being
she just came over like she wasn't
intending to kill her but it just things
went drastically sideways like they
started having an argument about it but
she insulted her because apparently they
had hung out before as at least as far
as I could determine and like she hadn't
killed her then obviously
yeah fighting over the same man she
probably insulted well you're not really
good enough to keep him that type of
deal I got him that kind of [__] yeah
she might have like some [__] like that
not blaming the victim I'm just saying
you [__]
she turned her back she [__] grabbed
that poker
and then she went oh [__] now I gotta
kill her yeah whoops
it's like that probably yeah
I was like she's smart I don't think she
was smart enough to plan anything out
anyway I think it was just spurtle above
and [__]
yeah and and like I said how weird she
acted after although the weird thing
about it was that after she was in
trouble yeah but after she got the
sentence they said she was like the
[__] calmest person ever but it's so
I don't really know she got resigned she
knew she was gonna hang she goes into
shock
so I mean basically the only defense
that they could come up with was that
well they didn't think that a woman of
her size because she wasn't a big lady I
think I mean I think she was a little
bit above average for a woman at that
time I think she was about five foot six
but she wasn't real Hefty or anything
she was just like regular signs and
they're thinking that because of the
brutality of the crime and the
physicality of it they were trying to
argue that she wouldn't have been able
to do it
but I don't think anybody bought that
because uh the jury only took 52 minutes
52 minutes
um and it was only a three-day trial to
like to give all the evidence and then
like on the third day they're like yep
she did it
um too much physical app is linking her
yeah yeah I mean
it was just [__] like I said she didn't
clean up anything there was just blood
all over her house it was like the
weapons were still there yeah open and
shut case and everything and she had
motive and and all that
um now she did say that she was innocent
that was because they always ask you
like you know do you have anything to
say about that and she said she was
innocent but the judge was like nope
yeah um and he's basically like yeah
we're gonna hang her we're gonna hang it
so as I mentioned uh it was actually
1907 before they passed that whole
appeal thing so there were no appeals
um her solicitor did actually make some
attempts on her behalf to say that well
she wasn't really responsible for the
crime because she suffered from like
epileptic fits and so maybe she had a
fit and like didn't know what she was
doing or something like that like they
tried to come at it from that angle that
was that was a terrible way
but again well like I said what choice
did they have they didn't really have a
lot of options open to them yeah
probably it had to be something Medical
be the only way yeah so that was the
argument that he used yeah he could
couldn't say well they got into an
argument she lost cool reasoning and
calm reflection she was she was
aggravated into it you know
that nowadays you could use that as a
defense and come up with manslaughter
you know it wasn't a murder it wasn't
planned
they were she was [__] with her and
she lashed out in the Heat of the Moment
but she couldn't take it back
yeah then she killed the baby see so
then it's real hard to get a [__]
manslaughter conviction because there's
two homicides they're gonna say no huh
yeah because the second one was fun well
yeah and I think that's kind of why
premeditated on the baby yeah I mean it
would have been something else if like
maybe you should have got away with like
manslaughter if if she let the baby if
she let the baby if she hadn't killed
the baby yeah thank you very much Bryce
very interesting subject this episode
Mary Piercy looks almost like a robot
yeah yeah I don't know what her [__]
problem was yeah I mean I don't know
what her thinking was she should have
just left the baby alive yeah
and that way if she did get caught then
she'd at least have a little bit of a
leg she might have still hung I'm not
saying that but she could have said it
was an accident they got into a fight
she tried to kill me and I was defending
myself that's why I didn't kill the babe
it's a different way you know it doesn't
have to be the truth that you just need
a defense in court
and as far as I know she didn't even
really try to try to
um argue that yeah that it was
self-defense like she came at me and
like right she wasn't thinking she's
dumb yeah she didn't seem like and who
knows probably in England at that time
they [__] you couldn't have the
refrital concept of self-defense anyway
well I don't know about that but I'm
just saying that it's just kind of like
I don't know it does seem like a lot of
the defense they tried to use were just
like oh she went temporarily crazy or
she had epilepsy or something like that
which I never heard of anybody like
having an epileptic fit that made him
kill somebody but usually despotic
tyrannies [__] don't have
self-defense somebody comes in your
house
[__] if you kill him then it's murder
because they say well he was just there
to rob you you don't know that you know
what I mean you didn't have to kill him
but um despotic despotic tyranny's hate
at all the populations so they're just
happy that he's dead and then they're
happy they're going to kill you in their
prison so that's why they do that
but yeah so even though um you know the
solicitor tried to argue like I said it
was a last ditch effort to just get her
out of the death penalty but um the
judge wasn't having it so basically yeah
we're gonna hang her now they said
despite her bizarre ass Behavior like
after the murder
um that once she was in custody and once
she had got the death sentence she was
pretty [__] cool as a cucumber
actually I think the the hangman said he
was like the she was like the calmest
person I ever hanged or whatever she was
just like totally chill which they
thought was like really really weird the
only time that she got upset
um that she showed any emotion
whatsoever was that she asked
um Frank to come visit her like before
she got executed like at new gate prison
and he didn't show up
and they were like and she was just like
inconsolable after that they said she
just stayed up all night crying that he
didn't show up to come see her before
she died
um but they said that was the only time
that she showed any emotion whatsoever
like the rest of the time she was just
totally totally calm which they thought
was very weird like like I said
especially considering how crazy she had
acted after the [__] whatever
now here's what she knew she was a goner
yeah that's why she was acting crazy she
knew there was no way out of it they
were gonna figure it out
yeah so she was just probably like why
bother yeah yeah making an effort she
was losing her mind she knew she was
gonna hang yeah and like I said you have
to think she was pretty young too she
was only 24 I think when she got
arrested yeah uneducated and dumb and
yeah but she knew you could get caught
yeah she was asking acting that way
she knew she was gonna get caught as
soon as she hit that girl in the head
where the [__] poker
yeah because it's almost like like I
said it's like she didn't even bother to
like try to cover it up really I mean
other than saying no [__] I didn't do
that but she didn't like try to hide
anything dumbass killed that baby though
yeah yeah
she had a fight with the mom there was
no reason to kill the baby
even though she was trying maybe she's
just trying to kill him both so she
could get the man
I think yeah I kind of thought that it's
like she was taking out his other family
so she'd have a chance of marrying so
that yeah but that may be reading too
much into it that might have been
something on a subconscious level
I don't think I mean that's what I
thought yeah you would think that but
like I said it's probably a subconscious
level yeah because if she was really
wanting that she'd have planned it a lot
better
yeah well they see that's another thing
that's kind of making me lean more
toward this being just like not
premeditated yeah no was that had it
been premeditated she would have like
you said maybe a lot better like she
didn't even clean the [__] up it was
just living still blood everywhere and
she just left the murder weapons laying
there and [__] yeah left the body like
not that far from the house just dumped
it on the road why would you want the
crime scene to be your house that's a
[__] dead giveaway
yeah somebody murdered in your house
like that's a little suspicious you know
why didn't you invite her over and this
is let's go for a walk and then go for a
walk and you kill her and then you go
then you call the police say man rob
this you know that would be more likely
yeah I ran you know I don't know what
happened
right see yeah that would have been like
a much better I'm not like giving people
advice like on how to murder people
I'm just saying that it's like there are
lots of better ways to go about any
idiot could come up with that they still
thought when they do that yeah they do
man oh I don't know what happened a man
a man came in
me and killed my children
black man carjacked me and killed my
children every time we haven't done a
show about that but there was like two
or three of those well I'm thinking of
like the most famous One what was her
name Susan she was the one that drove
the dam
fan into the water and yeah drowned the
kids yeah
yeah I don't think we've done a show
about her have we [__] maybe we should
there was also that other one that went
[__] crazy and drowned all the kids
in the bathtub oh yeah and and the
oldest one is no no mama please don't do
that you know and then no not me man you
imagine being a kid young enough old
enough to see the babies being drowned
knowing that you're I can't imagine man
the mama no please man
yeah that's [__] up
that's [__] up I don't know how
anybody could do that like yeah I think
she got off
from her correctly postpartum depression
yeah I might have to look into that case
because I I don't remember exactly what
ended up happening to her I don't think
they just like Let Her Off sex Scouts
she wanted some mental institution well
yeah they might have sent her to a
mental institution but that's not really
getting us got free right because like
well sometimes that's life anyway yeah
that's what I mean a lot of times they
it sometimes it's like you don't get a
sentence they just put you in there and
like they won't let you guess what
happened
yeah
but um that was back in the 80s I think
yeah I well yeah I can't remember
but okay so the weird thing about this
this is kind of like one of the enduring
Mysteries of the Mary Piercy case is
that the night before she was executed
she calls her solicitor who's you know
going through like all her final
requests like who's she's leaving her
[__] to and everything like that and she
very specifically said that she wanted
this ad to run in a newspaper not in
England in Madrid in Spain
and this ad read something to the effect
of
mecp Last Wish of Mew have not betrayed
that's what it said
now mew I'm assuming uh is her birth
name which was Mary Eleanor wheeler so
she's talking about herself
mecp nobody knows what that means now
some people have speculated and again I
think this is a little bit of a reach
but some people have speculated that
um mecp happens to be the first letters
of four of the canonical Jack the Ripper
victims
and so some people have speculated that
either Mary Piercy was Jack the Ripper
or Jill the Ripper as they call that
theory or knew who Jack the Ripper was
or was like um a you know a what do you
call an accomplice of his I don't really
buy that
um especially because the way that she
committed the crime seemed like I said
very much like a crime of passion just
committed because of jealousy or because
they had an argument or something like
that and not really the same way that
Jack the Ripper went about it
but nobody knows like what that
um what that message meant and a lot of
people have like speculated not not
necessarily that it was something having
to do with Jack the Ripper but
everybody's just kind of like wondering
what the [__] that even meant and who
the [__] she was even talking to because
I don't know if she'd ever even Been to
Spain she was probably damn fantasizing
about some dream man that lived in Spain
she's sending her last [__] love
letter to her
she's getting ready to get killed she's
her her brain ain't working right or
maybe she's just like I'm gonna [__]
with people I'm just gonna put this like
crazy ass [__] added here and then
like in like hundreds of years from now
people will still be wondering what the
[__] this means fantasy it's like so
[__] sounds like some cryptic sounds
like some kind of fantasy she had yeah
but so they asked her what that meant
but she like refused to tell anybody and
it's like she also she absolutely would
not confess either like she just said
she just said she was innocent the whole
time even though she was totally calm
about getting hanged but she did get
hanged you know uh crazy thing about
this was that
um you know Madame two sews
the wax museum very famous wax museum in
London I've been there actually it's
quite cool
um they have a chamber of Horrors and
they uh bought the pram from Frank oh
damn to put and they also made a wax
statue of Mary Piercy like not long
after she was hanged like to put in the
chamber of Horrors so you know quite
famous uh it around this time period so
that's the first case right yeah yeah
this one's warming up to the second case
yeah the second one we're gonna be
talking about this might be a good time
to ask you guys go ahead and hit that
like button and if hit share and
subscribe to the channel and we should
play some commercials if you ask me you
think play some commercials all right be
back in a second all right I'm gonna
play some commercials we'll be right
back in just a minute
oh
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
died
in the despairing postures
[Music]
and decay
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right we're back got ice in our
drinks we got everything like that thank
you very much Jeffy art guys yeah
[__] the little uh Super Chat little
team chat yeah
so uh yeah so you want to talk about
Amelia Dyer you know a little bit more
about this yeah case than you remember
the first one you told me about this
years back yeah we mentioned her on a
show
yeah I think we maybe did because the
thing about it is that
like I said they're not really entirely
sure how many
victims she had
if it's as many as they think it is then
she's easily the most prolific female
serial killer maybe the most prolific
serial killer in England
um yeah and maybe
I don't know she'd be up there that's
for sure like I said they can't prove it
they're just extrapolating from
uh you know how long she was operating
how many babies people saw coming in and
out of her care like neighbors and
things like that and how many of those
babies were not like accounted for you
know what I mean yeah
um and they did find a bunch of babies
in the Thames also like and in various
Rivers like near where she lived she
didn't kill all of them though because
like
this is [__] up but we'll get into why
this is but around this time period um a
lot of people were just kind of chucking
their babies in the river yeah
so you know we could do them with them
that's what I'm saying so this is pretty
it's pretty [__] harsh time
and that's what I was saying earlier
about how I'm not saying that she was a
product over time because well I mean
she was but I'm just saying that
that doesn't excuse what she did but I'm
just saying that in the in the framework
of the time it almost kind of like it
was almost inevitable that somebody like
this would come along well yeah they had
just a huge glut of unwanted children
and there's no means of taking care of
them you couldn't get him he couldn't
couldn't get him into any orphanages or
anything and somebody's going to
capitalize on that yeah and she came in
yeah there was no way to make money off
yeah it was like there was no regulation
of this uh of the service that she
provided yeah until later why would they
want to regulate it they didn't give two
shits about it yeah that's what I'm
saying yeah like afterward they did but
uh you know not so much they didn't
realize I don't think they realized the
magnitude what was happening yeah well
yeah I don't think they did until they
started like because
like I said she wasn't the only one that
was doing this there were some baby
Farmers that were legit that would
actually take in your baby and take care
of the baby but like some of them
there's a lot of exploitation in the
system going on yeah
so she wasn't the only one and actually
there was another woman I think her name
was Margaret Waters and she got um she
got caught doing it too and she got
hanged I think a couple of years before
uh Amelia Dyer did
so Amelia Dyer now they do know actually
quite a bit about her childhood
interestingly she did not come from
poverty
um she wasn't wealthy but she came from
a really really solidly middle class
household like her dad was a skilled
Tradesman he was a Shoemaker and uh she
was the youngest she had four older
siblings
but they were um actually pretty
comfortable and unlike about 75 percent
of the other kids in this strata like
she was actually really educated
um she went to like a church run school
so she had like a fairly privileged
upbringing for this time period you know
what I mean
so
um she uh it wasn't all just you know
roses and unicorn farts though because
her mom
got typhus at some point and began to
decline like she started having like
horrible hallucinations and she would
just like
you know she was just getting sicker and
sicker and she was getting crazier and
crazier there's another [__] shitty
water disease yeah that's what I mean
they didn't know any better just pooping
in the water and drinking it I'm telling
you it just never never believe that's
where that where that came from no it
was just sewage mixing in with food I
could give you typhus and water yeah
but yeah so yeah so the mom had that and
started having like all these fits and
stuff and because she was because Amelia
was the youngest daughter
um it usually fell on the youngest
daughter to like care for
sick family members or elderly family
members or something like that so they
speculate that probably she would have
been the one taking care of her mother
and like I said typhus is a pretty
shitty way to go
um and it took a while
so her mom died in 1848.
now after that uh I guess Amelia went
and lived with her aunts this was in
Bristol and then she started
apprenticing at like a corset maker
now her dad died in 1859 and then her
she had a brother named Thomas who was
older and he took over the shoe business
but Amelia she moved a little bit away
and then she got married
now she married this guy named George
Thomas now at the time that she married
him
she was 24 or 26 he was 59. now
interestingly they both lied about their
ages on the marriage certificate so it
wouldn't seem quite as weird she
actually added six years onto her age
and he subtracted 11 years from his age
so it wouldn't look like the Gap was so
big
um but yeah so he was uh for then that
he was quite elderly
so you know it that's kind of
interesting
so now so after after you married him it
seemed at first that Amelia was going to
have a completely respectable middle
class existence she actually went into
training as a nurse which in the
Victorian era was um I mean I'm not
saying it's not a hard job nowadays
because it is but back then it was like
way way
harder
um but yeah so she went into training
for that
and
basically what ended up happening though
was that while she was in her nurse's
training
she met this woman named Ellen Dane and
this was a pretty fateful meeting I
think that maybe kind of sent Amelia
down the [__] path that she went down
not saying she wouldn't have done it
anyway but I'm just saying that was this
was kind of like the catalyst
so Ellen Dane was a midwife
and she was also a baby Farmer on the
side like she would earn extra money
doing that
and she told Amelia all about the baby
farming gig
and Amelia was intrigued now
interestingly not too long after Amelia
and Ellen met each other Ellen actually
ended up getting in trouble for her baby
farmer stuff and she [__] up she like
came to the U.S she got the [__] out of
the country like because she was afraid
she was going to get arrested so there
was that
but see here's the thing the situation
of baby farming a baby farming is
essentially like unregulated
adoption is kind of what it is because
in the Victorian era if you were not
married like unwed mothers were super
super stigmatized there was basically
like no recourse for you if you got
pregnant out of wedlock
um you if you had a baby like orphanages
would not take them
um you could not work at a workhouse
even which was kind of like the lowest
of the low because they're like oh well
you have a kid and it's just not gonna
work out you're not going to be able to
work you know what I mean
um so you couldn't really do much of
anything so that's why I heard a
statistic and I don't know if this is
true but they said um one out of 12
women were prostitutes or had to work as
prostitutes which sounds like a lot but
it's just like considering the con the
conditions of the time probably not that
inaccurate I mean because they didn't
really have a lot of options well some
would have been too old yeah someone
would have been married didn't need to
some of them probably would have been
too young or working too hard
yeah it's probably about right wanna you
know [__] that's what I mean like
when they when I heard that I was like
wow that sounds like a lot but then like
when I was thinking about it I'm like oh
maybe it's not that's actually not that
maybe not yeah it's not that many
actually
but yeah you would think that it would
be more than that you'd think it'd be
like one-sixth yeah under those
conditions but no it's not but yeah so
if you were a woman and you got pregnant
out of wedlock you were pretty much
[__] and you were [__] even harder
after 1834. after 1834
they passed this law called the poor law
Amendment act now
the upshot of this what what the
supposed uh you know what this law was
supposed to do it was supposed to like I
said like encourage more Family Values
by discouraging people from having
children out of wedlock I'm like yeah
good luck with that
what it ended up doing so the poor law
Amendment act basically said that of
that if a guy got a woman pregnant he
had no financial obligation toward that
child at all like it absolved the man of
all responsibility which trying to keep
the women to keep their legs closed yeah
I mean I think that's that's yeah I
think that was the intention yeah um
obviously that is not how it worked out
yeah
um like I said it ended up blowing up in
their faces like severely because
yeah it just went so so now women had
even less recourse because it's like you
know you couldn't even get the dude to
marry you or anything like that you
could just knock a woman up and be like
bye not my problem yeah probably because
there was probably like a lot of
situations where women would get
pregnant on purpose to try to force a
man to marry them
that's probably what was happening so
they said oh no you can't do that you
can't have sexism before you're married
and then try to get him to marry you
that's a little South America trick
right there
um so they've made that law now he
doesn't if he gets you pregnant you're
[__] he could just walk yeah like I
said you were [__] before but now
you're like definitely [__] you're
right so they're probably trying to stop
women from doing that but then that just
they just made the situation worse yeah
it made it like exponentially worse it's
probably
better to just put it on the guy and go
look if you get these women pregnant
you're going to pay child support
and then the guys almost all of a sudden
but want to use birth control but here's
the thing a lot of times birth control
was illegal in these countries if you
couldn't have you could yeah yeah
[__] use a pig skin because that was
like you know we can't do that yeah
people will just have sex all the time
that was the thinking you know
which is dumb as hell that is dumb
it was just the mentality of the time
yeah and that mentality went on for a
long time it was even here in the United
States
all the way up into the [__] 20s 30s
I think some people still have that yeah
then it's like oh some people still
think that if you tell kids about birth
control oh they'll just be [__] all
day long I'm just like that's not really
yeah well they're [__] a child are
sticking anyway because we didn't get
any training on that we knew all about
that by ninth grade eighth grade you
knew all about that you didn't have a
sex ed class
to tell you about birth control stuff I
did if we didn't remember it and we
probably laughed at it that you know we
already knew they talked about STDs and
everything
I already knew that [__] by the time
well I did too but I'm just saying that
they did have a class in my public
school nobody knew about that [__] by
the time I was in fourth fifth grade
yeah well like I said I did too but back
in the late I think it was ninth grade
that they had the formal class that like
taught you all about that back in the
70s [__] we would get our hand we
could get our hands on porn
you know well yeah foreign
magazines back then we have [__]
stashes of that [__] out in the woods
yeah oh it's always always out in the
world yeah because you find it in the
garbage you're picking the garbage you
go he's got he's throwing them out you
know yeah yeah the wife found them you
can't take them home
gotta stick him somewhere so you're like
fifth grade you know I didn't [__] we
have a whole [__] Shack fill that
[__]
yeah I think a lot of boys did yep but
that's why you find porn in the woods
all the time yeah yeah that's right
because that's the only place they could
put it you couldn't put it up in a tree
house or nothing like that because your
mom might find it you'll find it
they had that [__] hidden inside of all
[__] plastic [__] uh bean bag
yeah because it was waterproof you can
zip it you put it in there with the
[__]
little white BBS it was the white foam
yeah I remember that you remember this
yeah it was yellow yeah Tammy said I
watched another YouTube channel called
briefcase oh I want yeah I know what
you're talking about I've seen some of
theirs too uh it deals with old crimes
most of the murderers seem to be young
women murdered by their baby daddies
um statistically
it is uh quite likely when a woman gets
pregnant
um that their partner will I mean it's
not super likely but if the woman gets
murdered when she's pregnant it's 99.9
of the time it's their baby daddy
um yeah so let me see okay so so what
this law ended up doing
um you know which duh
but now like dudes didn't have any
responsibility women were already kind
of hosed because it's like well you
couldn't take the kid orphanage you
couldn't go to the workhouse and like
you know make money which it wasn't a
lot but it was better than nothing so
it's like what the [__] are they gonna
do now
so
um so something came out called Baby
farming
so what a baby Farm was like I said it
was essentially like unregulated
um adoption sort of what people would do
was they would advertise in the paper
and they'd be like okay well we have a
home for like they would call it a
confinement home which I think is really
funny so it's like so if you're a woman
that's pregnant and your family doesn't
like disowns you or you don't want
anybody to know you're pregnant you go
and stay at this house and like hide
until you have the baby and that for a
nominal fee and then when the baby's
born
then either these people will maintain
the baby for x amount of dollars or
pounds per week or you give them a flat
fee and they'll be like oh we'll find a
home for it or we'll just adopt it and
take care of it you know what I mean in
theory that's what was supposed to be
going on and like I said some of the
baby Farms were legitimate like they did
legitimately find the kids homes or take
care right but like like I said now it's
it was all um they said the interesting
thing obviously it's mostly going to be
like you know working class poor people
stuff like that because they have the
least amount of options but they said
wealthy people would do it too because
you know wealthy girls also got knocked
up you know uh because everybody likes
sex you know what I mean so it's just
kind of like the rich girls were
probably doing it more yeah they
probably were so so their families were
ashamed of them obviously but they had
the means to be like hey let's pay this
baby farmer we're gonna stick you in
this confinement home for nine months or
whatever and then you have the baby of
them we're just gonna fob it off on
somebody else and No One's Gonna Be the
wiser you know what I mean you come back
and [__] up you'll know yeah that's
what I mean so that's what they were
doing and there were a lot of baby Farm
I think I was watching a documentary
earlier that said that during like this
time period there were 2 000 baby
farmers in London alone
at the in this time period 2000 in one
city
um so they're like so that should tell
you the extent of well they had a high
birth rate that's what I'm saying that's
the extent of like The Unwanted children
or and well the sad thing about it was
that a lot of the kids weren't unwanted
it was just that the women couldn't
afford to keep them because they
couldn't work they couldn't you know
what I mean so it's like they didn't
have the money so because a lot of the
babies and we'll see like with the
Amelia Dyer situation she ended up
getting caught just because some of the
mothers like wanted their babies back
and like they came there and be like hey
where's my kid you know what I mean like
you're supposed to be taking care of
them
um so some people did come back and
check and then they started getting
suspicious so it wasn't just that and
I'm not saying that some because some
women sadly
um did absolutely drop babies off at the
baby farmer with the understanding
perhaps that the baby farmer would toss
that [__] let the baby die yeah um they
would starve them or they would give
them a lot in them
which uh indirectly led to starvation
because it just made them lethargic and
they didn't cry anymore
um so they would overdose them just to
keep them quiet or whatever and then
like a lot of times in Asia yeah so um
so that would happen sometimes too but
like I said I I don't want it to seem
like everybody that dropped their baby
off there was just like hey I'm just
getting rid of the baby because some of
them did were did actually intend to
come back and get the kids just they
were in bad circumstances or whatever
and like that's what how like I said
Amelia dire ended up getting it just
those women were in a [__] tough
situation they're in a damn low-income
Urban environment in a world that has
kind of parochial country [__] values
of where you know no sex until marriage
and [__] if you have a if you have a
kid out of wedlock then you're [__]
you know what I mean that's that's just
a [__] that's just that was
old-fashioned even back in the 1800s
there had to be some kind of mechanism
to allow women to work
you know what I mean yeah and support a
baby as a single mother but that concept
wasn't there yeah they would just take
all their options away yeah yeah it was
almost kind of like well we're just
gonna punish you for opening your legs
you know what I mean but then the thing
about it's like what if they got raped
what if you know what if it wasn't
consensual what if they hadn't wanted to
get pregnant yeah then they're still
[__] they didn't seem to have the
concept that uh that uh that uh that
that a newborn was a person either that
was just yeah so that was just yeah you
don't need that you know what I mean
[__] because it can't talk so it's
not that it's not a person
so you know I mean it is pretty [__]
brutal it was brutal times but still
that [__] was kind of uncalled for
because all I had to do is just chase
some laws it says no you know if you're
a single mom you can keep the baby and
you can work and you can't say that you
you can't discriminate against hiring a
woman who's a single mom they could have
stopped that
well the thing about it I mean previous
to that stupid law where the dudes
didn't have any responsibility anymore
which was passed in 1834 prior to that
they had a little bit of a system where
it's like if you were unwed mothers or
at least you could go like the parish
would usually have like the church would
usually have some money set aside like
in every town or whatever to take care
of women in that situation and babies in
that situation so they did seem to have
a little bit set up like that but then
like after that law was passed they
didn't really have that anymore so like
I said they were kind of taking
everyone's options nobody had thought of
daycare
you just get a whole bunch of old ladies
together and you drop the babies off
with the old ladies and they take care
of the babies while the women are off to
work it's just that simple and then you
give the old lady a couple pennies a
piece
per baby per woman and then you know I
mean that's that's what daycare is but
for some reason these idiots never
thought of that and if you ask me
they were idiots they were idiots uh
yeah they were intelligent but there was
things about them that just uh were dumb
it was across the board although
although people are going to look back
at us and say that about us too you know
what I mean we're not all that
enlightened either 200 years from now
we're going to be considered Savages
yeah well like I said that's just gives
to show that like you know we do kind of
figure [__] out as we go along it just
takes us a while that's all yeah it
takes the first one somebody would have
thought you think the old lady well the
old ladies would have come up with that
well probably take care of these babies
somebody probably people did think about
it but it just wasn't enough to like
well because I mean you could think
about the baby Farmers
um the way it was set up was kind of
like a daycare
um in the sense that you would take the
kid and then you'd pay because some
people did actually pay they had a thing
that was called if you were a nurse
child nurse children yeah then you would
pay like you left the kid there but like
you gave them like money every week like
to look after the kid and you could come
back and visit anytime you wanted to but
it's like they would do it so like the
women could work you know they should
have done yeah they should have just
done it like a day Care Center yeah drop
the baby off during the day you go work
your shift or at night you work you
shifted in then you come get the bait
yeah and then you pay them yeah at the
end of the week yeah and that would have
been an easy solution
and the [__] baby Farmers probably
would have well they wouldn't have to
worry about getting hanged
so it probably would have made pretty
good money doing that
yeah I mean a daycare center see but
that's the thing and I think what the
thing that happened with Amelia Dyer and
the thing that happened with the other
illegitimate or like um you know the
evil baby Farmers was that they figured
well we're making all this money from
people dropping their babies off here
either permanently or temporarily
um but we still have to pay out money to
take care of these babies so it would be
better if we just got rid of the babies
and just kept the money yeah is
basically what they were doing and I
mean that's kind of where where Amelia
Dyer was at maybe they figured that the
mothers couldn't afford a daycare
service or something like that existed
anyway and they weren't didn't have the
money yeah well the thing about it was
that I mean some of them must have been
getting some money from somewhere
because Amelia Dyer made all kind of
[__] money yeah you know what I mean
um and sometimes like um because one of
the women in particular that um whose
baby she took who very much wanted the
baby and was like just inconsolable that
she couldn't afford to keep her and like
had to like drop her off
um she paid her 10 pounds which back
then was a lot of money you know what I
mean you that's ridiculous she had that
kind of money do you think that she
could just hire an end any some old lady
to [__] watch the baby for just you
know one old lady that wanted some extra
income take care of a baby for a couple
years
well like I said I mean the baby Farmers
that's what's going on too I think that
was probably going on too yeah
um and some of the baby Farmers I don't
want to make I mean baby Farmers it
sounds terrible and I and a lot of them
were
you know killing the babies or just or
not not even directly killing them but
just like neglecting them and like
leaving them to starve and stuff but
some of them did do what they said they
were gonna do it just seems like
you know I don't know what the
percentage was of ones that actually did
what they were supposed to be doing
versus no we're just gonna let your baby
down in New Zealand they're trying to
stop that trying to get us so women stop
trapping bed for getting here's the
thing I can kind of understand it more
back in those days back in the 1800s
because there was no way to prove
paternity yeah because you could have
just random women going it's his baby
pay me because they would start [__]
accusing people in the Royal houses and
[__]
this is Lord Rothschild's baby
you really couldn't prove it or disprove
it so
but now you can prove it you know if the
baby is yours then you're gonna have to
[__] chip in man
yeah and I mean you should it's like you
know you should want to that would I
don't understand I mean yeah you would
think right it's your own flesh and
blood why wouldn't you want to right
yeah that's kind of where how I feel
about it too yeah like I said maybe back
in the day maybe that was an issue
because you know you didn't have
paternity tests but now it's just like
very easy it's very easy to figure out
if that's your kid or not and if it is
your kid then yeah I think that you're
also partly responsible so
uh yeah
so as I mentioned
um some of these baby Farmers uh were
legitimate and did actually kind of run
like I said they would have they would
take the babies in and they would take
care of them some of them took in
pregnant women as well so they would
kind of like you know this is the
pregnant woman we could hide out and
then they would help them there were
midwives there and stuff and they would
help them have the babies and then they
would take the babies off their hands so
the women could go back to work for
whatever fee or whatever however
um as I mentioned some of these baby
Farmers figured out that you know it's
very time consuming and very expensive
to care for babies especially like lots
and lots of babies
so some of them figured out that well
maybe we should just um
let the babies uh die because
it's the Victorian era I mean seriously
um this is terrible but babies died all
the time it wasn't that unusual
um I think only like I think uh Camp guy
said earlier and this is this is I
believe an accurate statistic that 50 to
60 of babies didn't even live until they
were five years old just because you
know just because of the conditions it
was just you know the [__] sanitation
the medical care just like was just
shitty so a lot of babies didn't live
so it wasn't that unusual for babies
particularly among the working classes
to die of starvation or to die from what
are now very preventable illnesses so no
one thought it was all that unusual and
I think that some of the baby Farmers
did figure this out that it was much
cheaper to just take in all these babies
get the money and then just kind of like
just leave them laying around and not
feed them you know
um or like I said give them
[__] uh laud number or something like
that to keep them quiet which would
eventually lead to them starving as well
because they wouldn't eat uh one of the
things that they used that was that you
could just buy over the counter because
the Victorian era man you could just buy
all kind of drugs over the counter back
then uh still can in most countries well
yeah the one that they used was called
Godfrey's cordial uh and it was called
mother's friend that's what they called
it
and uh it was uh opium it was syrup with
opium in it and people did not bat an
eye about giving that to your baby if he
was being fussy
and if you gave your baby too much of
that
um then they could OD obviously or it
would also um make them real lethargic
and like I said suppress their appetite
so a lot of times too if you kept giving
it to them
um they would stop eating like they
wouldn't eat anymore because it took
their appetite away so they would
essentially starve to death so that was
um something that happened a lot I was I
was afraid I was um watching a
documentary earlier that said back in
this era it was absolutely not unusual
to just see like dead babies just like
laying in the [__] gutter you know
what I mean because people just oh baby
oh well yeah it's just like that's
[__] crazy it's [__] crazy like if
somebody if you saw dead baby nowadays
it'd be like lose their [__] and rightly
so you know what I mean it's just [__]
up that people would just be that
callous about it
you know what I mean it's just it's
[__] crazy
so yeah so like I said it wasn't unusual
for babies to die
um so no one really thought it was that
unusual that all these babies were
starving or whatever like in these baby
Farms
so because Ellen Dane This Woman This
Midwife that Amelia Dyer had met and
told
um Amelia all about this lucrative
practice
Amelia decided
um you know I might get into that well
she was kind of interested and then what
ended up happening was that her husband
George Thomas died
um you know and if you were a married
woman back in the Victorian era uh yeah
your husband died you were kind of
[__] you're just kind of like well
[__] now I don't have any money because
he was the one bringing her all the
money so she needed some a way to make
money now she was a nurse but I guess
that wasn't she worked at an asylum
actually
but I guess that wasn't pulling in
enough uh dough for her so she decided
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna try out
this baby farming thing that sounds like
pretty [__] easy and Ellen Dean had
told her that it was very lucrative as
well so she started running ads
um and she would tell them she was a
nurse she would tell them she was
married which was
technically true but I mean she had been
married but she was a widow actually
um and she would basically say yeah I'll
adopt your baby
um just give me a one-time payment give
me some clothes for the baby and I'll
take really good care of them I'm a very
stable woman I have nursing experience
yada yada and you know I will provide
like a loving home for your child
so she did that for a while now at first
I think that she did actually take the
babies in and kind of at least make a
rudimentary attempt at caring for them I
think
I don't think she just immediately
started was like man let's just kill him
you know what I mean but I think it
wasn't too long before she hit on the
idea you know it'd be much cheaper if we
just didn't have all these babies around
you know what I mean if we just took the
money in well probably the more she had
the less time she had to canvas for a
place to put him right she can go out to
[__] find him and then they started
piling up on her and she had no way to
get rid of him and they started to
starve yeah you know what I mean and
then she's like oh [__] well I'm gonna
speed this up then new business is
coming in the door yeah yeah just put it
right over there where's my
put it right over here
okay we got room for all kind of babies
that's so [__] up she might have had
it might have thought she'd actually
could actually do it think about it you
got to go find homes for these kids we
gotta run out of that real real soon
he's gonna run out of high yeah because
that was kind of the whole yeah I mean
the the whole premise of baby farming at
least in theory was that you were either
supposed to be like an adoption agency
you were supposed to find a home for
this kid yeah or you were supposed to
take care of the kids yourself like you
were supposed to adopt a kid essentially
he started backing up on her yeah she
could get rid of him
I just had like a really [__] up funny
mental image of like just piles of
babies like you have a seat I Love Lucy
with the Chocolate Factory
picture that but babies the babies
coming down coming down the the [__]
whatever you call it that's probably
what happened and then she got then she
got hardened to it
she's like well they're gonna die anyway
anyway nobody wants them
like I'm gonna speed this up and put
them out of their misery starts giving
him stuff or just tossing them overboard
well this is faster better than starving
and then you just throw it like that
yeah throw it into the water
yeah
uh Bryce said Bryce is the one that said
about the New Zealand law about men not
paying child support uh then he said I
don't understand deadbeat dads
look at lots of kids they don't want any
any more of them evidently I guess but
like I said you know if that's your kid
then yeah you should probably take some
responses some dudes are psychos
uh duh yeah yeah I know that but
should I you know I know that people
should take responsibility for their
[__] but a lot of people don't which is
sad but I will
so yeah so after a while like I said she
wasn't I think at first she wasn't just
like straight up murdering them that
came later
but she was just neglecting them like I
said she was drugging them or just not
feeding them or whatever like when they
were starting to back up she's like oh
well they're just like dying and she
would just like dump him someplace
now so many babies were dying though
that in 1879
um a doctor got suspicious because he's
like you know there's been like [__]
I think he got suspicious because there
have been like over a two-week period or
something like that there had been like
[__] a dozen babies or something like
that like died in this one house and
he's like yeah that's a little unusual
so he actually
um
wanted to he actually kind of like uh
reported her
and they went and investigated now they
didn't find any dead babies at her house
which would have been which would have
been like a red flag I'm sure
but they did find some babies that were
there that were obviously ill or had
obviously been neglected or hadn't been
fed or anything like that so Amelia Dyer
was actually arrested in 1879. however
because there was no
um proof that she had actually killed
any of the babies
she only ended up getting six months for
neglect right now it was six months hard
labor
which
I'm sure was not fun but I I was
listening to another documentary that
said what they would do like for a lot
of times so especially like for the
women like hard labor like obviously
they would make them like you know do
like horrible like cleaning and all this
other kind of stuff they're like they
would do this one thing where there was
like some kind of rope or something like
that and they would make you UNT like
take each of the little like things like
off the Rope like pull it all apart like
with your bare hands unwind a rope yeah
like just pull it all apart like with
your bare hands like all day long like
so all your nails would break off and
like you're [__] because it ain't
work for you to do so they just so they
would just like give yes so they would
give you like I don't know if that's
true but I was like watching the
documentary that said that that was one
of the things they did
but yeah so a lot of people were kind of
like offended because she only got six
months but like I said they couldn't
prove that she had killed killed any of
the babies because a lot of babies did
die of starvation stuff it was like a
really brutal time you know what I mean
and a lot of them were poor so they
couldn't really prove that she had
killed them
um but for sure they're like okay well
there is evidence that she neglected
them but she only got six months which
is crazy I mean that's still like pretty
lenient even for that you know what I
mean but like I said like we were saying
before I feel like in this era they
didn't really
feel like it was almost like a baby
wasn't like a full person you know what
I mean
so it so it wasn't considered like as
important as if he'd killed like an
adult no you know what I mean like
another species or and even like little
kids I feel like they didn't really
value children as much as like they do
nowadays you know what I mean it really
didn't seem like they did it was
something like a dog or a cat yeah
they're just like oh well we got lots of
those yeah
so yeah so she did six months hard time
and apparently
after she got out of jail
um she was different
um the thing about Amelia Dyer uh for
one thing she was a big laudanum addict
um and she got into that like and it
just got worse and worse as she got
older
um and they think maybe that she started
to like loser marbles a little bit but I
don't know if that's the case I think
she was kind of Faking but we'll get
into that in a little bit
one of the things though was that when
she got out of jail she's like I don't
ever want to go back there ever again so
it was almost kind of like because it
was so horrible but she was like
kind of resolved she actually resolved
for a little while to go straight
because she was so afraid of going back
to jail
so she actually did when she got out
like tried to go back to her nursing
career
um and she would go and work at UH
mental asylums and things like that now
she also spent time not working at
mental of you know hospitals but inside
them because like I said she had a lot
of addiction she had some kind of like
uh she attempted to Suicide like several
times things like that she was not a
role stable individual although like I
said a lot of the mental illness I think
later on at least I think she was
probably faking
but um you know what I mean she was also
a drunk so there's that as well
now one of the things that happened so
you know so she had been doing like all
of this [__] for a while like she was um
she tried to get back to nursing but I
guess she only did that for like a year
or two and then it's like it's almost
like she couldn't resist
and she went back to Baby farming even
though like I said she was terrified of
going back to jail because it had been
so horrible couldn't resist that money
she couldn't yeah I think that's what it
was I think she was just kind of like
the money was so sweet that she was like
yep I'm just gonna go back and do that
even if I do get caught even if I do
have to kill these kids yeah well and
that's pretty much what it ended up
doing it's just kind of like she was
doing that before right
and so the thing about it was that well
if I'm not killing them somebody else is
going to kill them they're going to get
the money yeah
and I mean she almost got caught like so
many times too like because she did this
off and on mostly on for like 30 years
you know what I mean like she got away
with it for a long time she got away
with it for a long time and she almost
got caught a bunch of times like for
example 1890 she actually because after
she got out of jail and she decided she
was gonna go back into baby farming she
decided that she was gonna try and go
for like a higher end clientele like
they could afford to pay her more money
more money right so this one family like
a wealthy family I guess their daughter
or the governess or something like that
she had gotten Knocked Up by somebody
like
um like the I guess like the the rich
guy's son or something like that and
they wanted to keep it hushed up
obviously
so she has the baby and she hands it off
to Amelia
and then the girl comes back to check on
her baby because she's like I think that
woman's kind of sketch and so like she
goes back to check on the baby and
Amelia straight up she's like no your
baby's right here and she's like yeah
that's not my baby and she's like yeah
it is um you know babies change a lot
like in three months or whatever and
she's like pull that blanket aside
because the baby had a birthmark on
their hip and that baby didn't have that
right so Amelia was like trying to pawn
another baby yeah off on this girl and
she was just like yeah not having it now
you know right they all look alike yeah
right but yeah I mean even even before
she like looked at the birthmark she was
like that's not my baby I mean it's her
baby she knows what the baby looks like
so this girl like reported her
and when she got reported and this
happened more than once Amelia
um did like a suicide attempt like she
drank two full bottles of laudnam which
would have killed most people but she
was like an addict so she was like in
order to she was resistant to it so it
didn't kill her like it almost did but
it didn't kill her and she started
acting kind of crazy and so they
actually put her in an asylum for a
little while now some people have
speculated they're like well it's
possible that she was like just really
that mentally unstable but they pointed
out that one her mom
um had had like a typhus and she had
like all those like fits and
hallucinations and everything like that
and also
um Amelia had worked as a nurse in an
asylum and would have known what
quote-unquote crazy people Behavior
looked like and would have known like
what symptoms to feign in order to get
locked up in the hospital so some people
have speculated that she was just
because whatever it looked like she was
gonna get caught for some [__] she'd be
like crazy I'm crazy you know what I
mean and she'd get put in the hospital
okay now the girl who came back looking
for a baby says that's not mine how long
ago had she given that baby to her three
months I think I think it was three
months so she killed that baby in a
couple of months she thought that she
wasn't coming back
which client didn't come back well some
of them didn't yeah but what she would
do is that well okay well she did a
couple of things one she would try to
keep she would keep like pushing [__]
off like she would write them letters
being like Oh your baby's fine yada yada
and then what another thing she would do
she kept one she kept changing her name
like she would uh she had like a bunch
of different aliases and if she thought
the heat was getting too much at one
place she like got the [__] out of there
and moved someplace else so she yeah so
she would like move around so I think
that was another thing that made it like
um taken a really long time to catch her
because the thing about it like I said a
lot of people that dropped the kids off
you know some of them did come back and
like visit the babies and [__] like that
but a lot of them probably did it back
no nobody got their baby back not as far
as I know no
damn so she killed all the babies
yeah I think I think she did I did hear
there was like they were talking about
there was this one little boy
that lived at the house that was a nurse
child who I'm assuming he wasn't a baby
anymore because he could talk and
everything like that but I guess so I
guess she didn't kill all the babies but
I think she killed pretty much all the
babies
and sometimes she would keep him for a
little while but because sometimes like
I said she would just like let them die
of like neglect or whatever but after a
while
she started like just straight up
killing them like as soon as she got
them you know what I mean because it's
like she just didn't want to waste time
anymore I guess and okay
and most of the clients didn't come
looking for him anyway I mean I would
imagine not or she would have been
caught right before that right
so she must have known the statistics or
she kept fobbing the or she kept like
fobbing them off like just saying it's
like oh you know the baby's fine or
another thing she would do I'm gonna
give him a new baby well another thing
she would do too is that because some of
the people like left the babies there
like to be adopted out and she'd be like
oh your baby got adopted by this nice
family and wherever you know what I mean
and she'd be like real cagey about it
but she's like yeah the baby's fine we
we gave him this look to this loving
family over here and blah blah and like
some people are like oh that's good what
a relief or whatever but
I don't know it seems like some people
did kind of try to look into the [__]
but I don't think a lot of people look
too much into it or she would have been
caught prior to because like I said she
was doing this [__] for a long time and
like I said she did move around and like
use different aliases and whatnot so
that probably now the women that came
back for the babies she was under
explicit orders to keep they keep the
baby for a certain amount of time and if
they were going to come back for it well
the setup was it was a different setup
like for different people some people
would come and just give her a flat fee
and just leave the baby there with the
understanding that she was going to find
a home for that baby or she was going to
adopt the baby herself that was like the
one time fee thing now you also had
nurse children which were a baby that
you would drop off and the baby would
stay with them but you would pay like a
weekly maintenance fee yeah with the
understanding that you were allowed to
come back and visit whenever you wanted
she was losing track of which one of
them probably she was losing track I
mean because he was a nurse according to
her neighbors and things like that a lot
of babies went through that house a lot
um some people said it was as many as
like six or seven a week like so it was
like one a day pretty much um and there
were like some days it was like more
than that it was like five or six babies
a day she did this for 30 days 30 years
pretty much like you're talking about
thousands of kids well like I said they
think like extrapolating their like even
by conservative estimate it's probably
four or five hundred babies at least
that she killed probably so okay
wow so she must you would think that
she'd be smart enough to go well they're
paying she keeps getting these checks
for kids coming in each month yeah
so she's getting residuals on kids that
are supposed to be alive
you think she could have kept straight
which ones were nurse children maybe she
just didn't give a [__] yeah maybe she
would just go well I'll do it for a
little while and I'll move
before they show up yeah because she
would move around a lot and like I said
back then you could just change your
[__] name you want to get the drop of
a hat and nobody would be the wiser he
just moved to the next town and it's
like hey I'm Mr Smith now you know what
I mean everybody's like okay fair enough
so I think it was that kind of situation
also and like I said she was really
good at coming up with stories
um for people that inquired about their
babies saying yeah we adopted into this
family here and it could be that nurse
children would be there for a couple
months and usually the checks would stop
coming
yeah baby yeah baby so maybe so and then
you're like okay well this kid's a goner
might be something like that yeah too
but that one girl came back yeah maybe
she couldn't keep him straight didn't
bother to keep them straight putting
names on the babies and [__] she printed
heavy names well like I said she might
have been one of those [__]
like ah they all look alike they're all
the same whatever this baby that baby
yeah yeah who cares whose baby it is
yeah they're all just white babies just
take a baby yeah let's take it
no different but um but yeah so uh so
yeah so because she had almost been
caught because of the doctor you know
being like why are there so many babies
dying at your [__] and she's like well
you know what um this is like a mugs
game like calling the doctor to certify
the deaths
um you know so it looks all above board
and everything so [__] it I'm just gonna
start getting rid of the bodies my own
self and then not even involve the
authorities at all because you know
that's a rookie mistake I guess
so she did um go back to after her like
freak out and her suicide attempt and
they put her Asylum and everything like
that but after she got out
um she went back to Baby farming and at
this point like I said she's like I'm
not even gonna bother calling doctors
anymore and I'm just going to basically
uh when the babies are dropped off she's
just gonna kill him and dispose of their
bodies like right away you know what I
mean so what she would do
is they would drop the baby off now I
think too that
um sometimes like I said because I think
she also partially ran like a
confinement home like for pregnant girls
so like when women would come there that
were pregnant and she would like take
care of them for a little while because
she had like some midwifing experience
and [__] like that too and sometimes
what she would do
and I think other baby Farmers did this
too is they would help the woman have
the baby but then they would smother the
baby like as soon as it came out the
womb and they're like and what you they
would usually do is they would do it
like right away because if you didn't
then the baby would breathe and then
like if you try to smother them after
that then they turn blue instead of
everybody be like oh well the baby was
breathing what the [__] happened so they
tried to make it look like a stillbirth
is what they would do which like I said
was wasn't unusual no no I don't think
the mom was in on it I just she didn't
really know what was going on what did
they have to gain from that she said she
didn't want the baby well no but she had
already but she had paid like you're
right right okay yeah yeah
so there's that they're like oh too bad
so sad like your baby is stillborn you
know what I mean but you still owe us
money so yeah you know what I mean it
was that kind of situation so they would
do that kind of [__] too so what she
would start doing was that the person
she would run an ad the person would be
like okay well you know take my baby for
10 pounds or however much it was you
know and please find the baby at home
she would take the baby take the baby
home and then she would take um you know
dressmakers tape that they use to like
tape up um hems and [__] like that if
you were sewn she would take
dressmaker's tape and just tie it in a
knot around the baby's neck and just
watch them
watch them suffocate watch them strangle
yeah and
um then she would wrap the baby up in
like brown parcel paper tie it up with
string put a brick in there and throw it
in the river
so that's what she would do
um and after a while and she even said
this out loud
um and I like I said I don't think she
intended to start out doing this but
after a while I think she started to
enjoy it because she even said out loud
that she like she liked watching the
babies like with the tape around their
necks you know what I mean so I think
she was kind of getting off on it after
a while
yeah
who'd she say that to
I think she maybe said that after she
got caught like that was like in her
because she wrote like this big long
confession like after she got caught
but yeah so um
so 1893.
um she had been confined to a mental
Asylum again because like I said it
seemed like she was gonna get caught so
she's like I'm crazy I'm crazy she did
that she pulled that Shenanigans again
so then they let her out and she was at
um a work house
and she met this old lady who was in her
70s whose name was Jane Smith who they
called Granny Smith not like the Apple
I'm assuming
now Amelia goes to this woman and
basically says hey I have a baby Farm I
don't know if they called it that but
she's like I have a baby Farm
and you'd be perfect you could come to
my house and help me take care of all
these babies and we're gonna save all
these unwanted babies and all of a
sudden she gave her like this really
like [__] she gave her old [__]
line you know what I mean and Granny was
like all into it she like granny didn't
know what the [__] like she she didn't
know that Amelia Dyer was a total
monster right she like totally bought
into she's like I love babies I would I
will help you take care of babies so uh
Jane Smith moved in and what ended up
happening though was that Amelia at that
point and like I said this is like
Amelia at this point I think was in her
40s or 50s but you know Granny was like
70 something and she'd been in a
workhouse and back then like they didn't
have social security or retirement or
nothing like that it's like you
basically if you were poor you were in a
workhouse if you could work you worked
otherwise they were just like get the
[__] out and you just like [__]
starved in the street is what happened
but yeah so this old lady was basically
like okay well it's better than the
workouts but she ends up at
uh Amelia's house and Amelia ends up
just like hey why don't you like [__]
clean my house and cook so she like put
her to work basically
so um also they she had help from and
there's kind of speculation about this
too but she um Amelia this might
surprise you but she had a daughter also
um whose name was Marianne even though
they called her Polly and her daughter
had married and so they were also
helping out around the baby farm and
like later on there was some speculation
about how much they knew about it like
about what what was going on but like I
said we'll get into that a little bit
um so yeah so then they moved
and then
um
Amelia started using granny as kind of
like to burnish her images like look
this is kindly old lady and
um and I'm just and I'm her daughter you
know what I mean like they like she
would call the old lady granny and she
told granny to call her mother so it's
like so they would look all wholesome
and [__] so that was like another way of
like I said granny didn't seem to know
anything about the nefariousness of what
was going on she just kind of got roped
into this [__] but um but yeah so
Amelia was totally using her as you know
a grandmotherly type stuff so people
wouldn't be as suspicious right because
like I said she moved so she was
starting anew
so one of the cases
um that gets brought up a lot this is
like and this is very emblematic of like
what she would do was there was this
woman this was this happened in 1896.
this woman named um Evelina Marmon and
she was a bar maid she was 25. and she
got pregnant out of wedlock and she had
a baby daughter whose name was Doris and
this was in um Cheltenham
now she actually put an ad in a in the
newspaper
um for someone to care for Doris or to
adopt her because she you know she
couldn't afford to take care of her even
though she very much wanted the baby but
she couldn't afford to take care of her
so um she run an ad and the ad said
wanted respectable woman to take young
child
um you know so she could go back to work
because she you know obviously needed to
work now in the same newspaper crazily
was uh Amelia's ad
Amelia's ad said married couple lie uh
with no family would adopt healthy child
nice country home 10 pounds
so
um Evelina was kind of like okay well
that sounds exactly like what the doctor
ordered right so she wrote to this woman
now at this point Amelia Dyer was using
the pseudonym Mrs Harding that was what
because like I said she was she was Mrs
Harding she was Mrs Thomas she was she
had all the kind of different names
so um so yeah so Mrs Harding AKA Amelia
Dyer she writes her she writes back to
Evelina and she's like laying it on
thick oh I've you know I've always
wanted a little baby girl
um I would bring her up and call her my
own and bloody blush like she really
like gave her a [__] line right
um and she's basically like uh I don't
want a child for money's sake but for
company and Home Comfort myself and my
husband are dearly fond of children I
have no child of my own yeah and like I
said this is all complete [__]
so basically Evelina she went there and
she didn't necessarily want to just give
a one-time fee and like give her
daughter away you know what I mean she
wanted to do more of like a weekly thing
you know she's like I'll pay a little
bit a week and then when I can afford to
take the baby back I'll take the baby
back you know because she wanted to keep
the baby
she just couldn't afford to but
um eventually Amelia was able to talk
her into no just give me the 10 pounds
and I'll take your kid you know what I
mean and uh Evelina was not super happy
about it but just like she didn't really
know what else to do and she was kind of
like desperate
so she actually gave Amelia the baby uh
Doris and gave her 10 pounds and gave
her like a box of the baby's clothes and
uh sadly they left at the train station
and that was the last time that Evelina
ever saw her daughter alive again
um so yeah she wrote to Mrs Harding and
said hey how's the baby doing and you
know Amelia writes back and she's like
oh she's totally fine everything's fine
I'll write you again on the weekend but
she never wrote back she just didn't
so basically
um
as soon as Amelia got home with this
baby
she did what she did with the other
babies with the dress making
tape and all that strangled it yep
and uh yeah
so then they wrapped the baby up in like
a napkin
and uh they took some of the clothes to
a pawn shop which is [__] up
and uh also gave some of the kids
clothes to like their landlady like for
her daughter which again is pretty
[__] up
and uh then they also they had there was
another baby who happened to be this is
[__] up too because it seemed like
when whenever the authorities like
searched the house they did find like
some Alive babies that were kind of like
sickly or whatever but they never found
any dead babies but at one point there
was a dead one like and I'm like how
does this situation arise you have all
these babies and it's like there's like
a like a baby like a dead baby like in a
package like in a Cupboard somewhere
what and then it's like and then it was
in there for a while because it like
started to stink until somebody like I
don't know how long it was in there
yeah and it was just like well what you
didn't like
well I'm just gonna tuck this dead baby
up here in the [__] what the [__] is
that all about and I was just like I was
horrified when I [__] heard that
um so yeah well you said that just
talking dead baby's up and it reminds me
of uh I saw um
this Urban exploration it was either in
Detroit or somewhere in Baltimore
there was an abandoned uh
embalming place like a mortician's house
somebody called that funeral home yeah
and they were going through there and
they were they were um
still bodies in there
and they left it there a long time and
one of them was a bunch of boxes little
babies that were up up in the ceiling
five I hated to be the person that
opened that box yeah five well they were
mummified still they were mummified in
there they called the cops cops showed
up there was a [__] box of babies up
in there
yeah and it was because the I'm always
afraid it's going to be something
Funeral Home the funeral home [__]
was going bankrupt and they were just
taking people's money and the bodies and
then not processing them oh I remember
hearing about that kind of [__] yeah and
uh the place had been [__] abandoned
and evidently because those people were
all legally dead and the paperwork done
and everything nobody came to [__]
dispose of those bodies they just stayed
in there
yeah they're the counties I gotta [__]
them
well I mean yeah they're already on
record as being dead [__] they're
just not buried they're in that in in
that [__] building that's [__]
creepy that is creepy yeah that sounds
like a Horror Story waiting to happen
yeah right there they're gonna get up
and start walking around yeah
that guy who was embalmed
and just in in a in a like a cardboard
box or casket he was in a casket he was
embalmed though but he was just sitting
there
ah yeah he looked pretty [__] stale
oh that guy he looks pretty [__]
stable well let's see how you look after
being dead for that long I've been in
there a couple years they've bombed
yeah yeah all right so uh so yeah so she
had killed Doris the baby with the white
edging tape and then I guess she also
had another baby laying around that
needed killing
um but she didn't have any
edging tape left
so she took the tape off of Doris's neck
and then wrapped it around this other
baby's neck because you know economical
um this other baby's name was Harry
Simmons it was like a little boy
so then she takes he was 13 months old
so then she takes both of these bodies
pretty old yeah that's like over a year
old that's tight like toddler age yeah
yeah so this wasn't like a newborn you
know
I don't know how long she'd had it had
him you know what I mean I don't know
how long she's been big enough to fight
back
well I don't know one year old I don't
know about it one year in the one year
old big enough to kind of
resist I guess but it's still a baby
yeah you know she was she was a big
Stout woman yeah so it was like in her
50s
but um yeah she was she looked like a
big Bruiser actually
but so she puts two uh these two babies
in this carpet bag and then puts a bunch
of bricks in it and then they went over
thank you Victor hey I made it yeah
Victor man tell you what man
all these uh
all these what do you call this all
these baby forms made you gay
baby Farms baby Farms made you good you
missed it this is a [__] up story so
[__] up bro and I've been like
watching documentaries about the about
these two cases for like the last two or
three days and it's just like this is
really bumming me out this I mean and I
watch True Crime all the time and it
doesn't bump but for some reason this
one really bums me out
because it's a lot of babies and it's
just and I don't understand how anybody
could do there's excess population and
she was taking care of it I mean
single-handedly Jesus Christ think of
all the [__] I mean if it was really
400 babies which like I said is not
crazy I mean it sounds crazy but it was
a long time period that she was
operating yeah and it's not when you
think about it in context that's really
only
only a few a month you know what I mean
which that sounds pretty reasonable to
me like considering what she was doing
the saddest part is that some of them
girls wanted those babies and trying to
come back for them yeah that's what's
[__] up and it's like it's just
heartbreaking yeah it's heartbreaking
so yeah so she puts these two babies in
this carpet bag and puts a bunch of
bricks in there and then she
um throws them into the Thames
now interestingly
um right around the same time
I think like a day or two uh March April
like prior to this
there was a guy in the Thames he was a
barge man so he was like you know on a
little boat or whatever
and he found a package in the Thames
that had a dead baby in it
um a baby girl now this was a different
baby this baby was named Helena Frye
and he obviously went to the police he's
like hey I found a package with like a
dead baby in it that's not right now in
this particular package which had I
guess she had tried to weight it down
but it hadn't worked she didn't put
enough weight in it or something like
that because it was still kind of like
floating
now when they opened this box and found
the dead baby in there the paper that
the baby had been wrapped in had
um like a train ticket from Temple Maids
station in Bristol and it also had
um a name and an address on it now the
name was Mrs Thomas they didn't know
that was one of her um aliases at the
time but they found it later on but it
did have the address on it so they were
able to figure out like from this
address they went and you know
interviewed all the neighbors and stuff
like that and they were able to
triangulate and figure out that Mrs
Thomas was actually Amelia Dyer you know
what I mean why the hell would she have
that [__] in the in there with that baby
because she's a dumbass damn
she's a dumbass like I said these are
not baby batter made me gay the baby bad
or baby butter baby batter maybe better
oh yeah yeah
let's talk about now I'm not gay I
didn't I didn't have the
I thought that was pretty common no I've
heard it lots of times never heard of
that I've Heard lots of times it's a
girl thing it's not a girl thing dudes
have never called it that
I don't think I've never heard any dudes
ever call it that well yeah well you
don't know every dude in the world
[Laughter]
well you have a favor it's just like
well I've never heard of it so therefore
it doesn't exist
I've heard that a lot of times I've
heard a lot of people say that kind of
dudes I hang out with
it okay well that's fair enough
um but yeah warlocks motorcycle clubs
not gonna [__] call it very better
well well no but other people other
people
call it
I mean I think that's kind of a gross
phrase but it is kind of funny the
batter that makes babies yeah like
pancakes yeah pancake babies yeah
pancakes but um
all right it's making Victor gay and it
makes Jenny want pancakes so we're
waffles that would be good too
um but yeah it makes her hungry yeah
just hear it
so dirty it's a dirty though yeah but um
it's terrible but yeah so uh so yeah so
they see this address they actually do
figure out it's Amelia Dyer now there's
not enough just because the paper is in
there that doesn't necessarily mean that
she killed the baby right I mean it
could be lots of it maybe maybe whoever
killed the baby got the paper somewhere
else or something like that like I said
it's not definitive even though we know
you know and I know that she was the one
that killed that baby but you know what
I mean they can't prove it
so what they decided to do so they do
like all of these um they interviewed
all these Witnesses and stuff like that
and then they decide that they're gonna
put her under surveillance like so for a
while because they did that back then
too which is crazy but yeah so they put
Amelia Dyer under surveillance because
they're like let's see what this [__]
is up to
so they and also they decided and this
was like actually pretty good thinking
for
Victorian area of era police not only
putting her under surveillance but
they're like we're gonna do a sting
operation and we're going to
um you know recruit a young woman who
ostensibly has a baby to give her and
we're gonna see how that goes down you
know what I mean so they did do that
like so they kind of like set everything
up so they set a meeting and everything
like that now because of the way that
they set the meeting up
she's supposed to go meet this girl who
was actually like the bait in this trap
or whatever and then when Amelia Dyer
like showed up at the meeting like it
was actually the authorities and they
were just kind of like you're under
arrest [__] pretty much
um but yeah so it was that they uh and
then the cops raided her house
and when they went in there
um they didn't find any bodies although
the whole house smelled like human
decomposition so there was that
um but they did find a bunch of other
evidence even though they didn't find
anybody because they did find like a
whole bunch of the white dressmakers
taped just like the kind that had been
found because the thing about it was
that after they found
um those babies in the Thames
they started searching or and they found
I think one documentary said they ended
up finding like 50 babies she didn't
kill all of them I don't think because
she said to the cops this is [__] up
she said to the cops she was like oh
well you'll know which ones are mine
because of the white tape
so I guess that like they found some
other ones that didn't have that she's
like yeah I didn't do that one like that
was somebody else which like I said
that's [__] up right but like I said
back then there were a lot of unwanted
children so not everybody like sometimes
people would have babies and their
babies would die or they would starve or
whatever and they would just throw it in
the river because everybody just throw
everything in the Thames back then it
was so polluted but yeah so she
basically said that's how you'll know
which dead babies are mine because
they'll have the white tape around their
necks that's how because they found
other ones they found like 50 babies
when they like started crawling around
in there it's funny how she left the
tape on the neck that's like a serial
killer thing that's what I mean see
that's why I think
I don't think because nothing in her
history like suggests that she was like
super messed up or like you know serial
killer material or anything like that at
least that I know of but I think as time
went on I think she started out
with the baby I don't think she intended
at first to just get to kill all these
babies I think at first she's like she's
like oh well I can make more money if I
just let them die which other baby
Farmers did too to be fair because it's
cheaper so I think at first it was just
pragmatic concerns she was just trying
to make more money but then after a
while I think she just got kind of
ignored to it and then I think she
started to get off on it it seemed like
to me I don't know I don't know her and
she's been dead a long time but just the
progression of the crimes the way that
they progressed it did seem like she got
a taste for it after a while and she was
kind of getting into it yeah like messed
up why leave the [__] string around
the neck right you could just remove
that
you're leaving a calling card on it yeah
and it's almost like she seemed kind of
proud of it because she does tell the
cops when they found all those dead
babies in the river
that you know you'll know which ones are
mine because of that
so it's almost like she was proud of it
yeah like the way she's marking them so
I think after a while even though I
don't think this is what she intended
from the start but I think like as the
years went on
she kind of started getting to like
enjoy it yeah because if you find the
baby and it's got that tied around its
neck you know that baby was killed yeah
it wasn't still born or anything it was
right yeah because if you just threw it
in the river like you could say oh well
it was born down or or it starved or
whatever but it's like that's you know
that pretty much takes away all doubt
like that you know the baby was murdered
yeah that's weird but yeah she was
marking it yeah so that's why I think
that after a while she just started
getting into it like getting off on it
um which is very serial killer Behavior
yeah I don't think she intended it she
started out like that but I think it was
just practical at first but became
learned behavior yeah I mean killing
that many babies
that I mean that obviously is gonna
Harden you right I mean
yeah I can't imagine doing that one time
much less 400 times or how many [__]
times she did it maybe more
so I mean she's uh she can't these are
babies that are born
you know what I mean [__] that's
that's cool but that's what I mean that
is like [__] that is like I don't
imagine I don't know how anybody could
do that I don't know
um like I said I can't even [__] I
can't even kill a bug really so it's you
know I can't even kill a spider so much
less
so much less like a baby that's like
squalling and stuff I don't I can't
imagine
so yeah so they raid her house
um like I said they didn't find any
bodies in there but it stunk like like
human remains
um they did find uh all of the like all
the dressmakers tape
um they found like just a treasure Trove
of telegrams about
um you know people contacting her and
like her making arrangements to like
pick babies up and [__] like that they
found like a whole bunch of Pawn tickets
for children's clothing because that was
another thing she would do she'd take
their clothes and shoes that the parents
brought for the babies and then she
would just go pawn it for money that was
another thing she did so that's shitty
um also had like all the ads that she
had run
and all of the letters that from the
moms like writing to her like asking how
the babies were and [__] like that so
they found all that like in her house
now they calculated that just in the
last couple of months before they raided
her house
that they're at least according to
neighbors and Witnesses and stuff like
that there had been at least 20 babies
going in there and not coming out again
alive so at least 20 just in the couple
of months before they caught her
um and they thought too like when they
raided her house it looked like she was
starting to pack up to move again
because she thought like the heat was
getting too much right was she living
large
um I don't know I don't think she was
not I never saw anything that said she
was like living conspicuously wealthy or
anything like that so she wasn't making
that much profit off I mean apparently
it was a very lucrative business but I
don't know if she was like showing off
the wealth I think she was too worried
that she was gonna get caught because
like I said a couple years before she
got caught there was another woman named
Margaret Waters I think her name was
Margaret Waters and she was doing a
similar thing and she got caught and
hanged and that kind of freaked um that
kind of freaked Amelia out and she like
went kind of on the down low for a
little while because she was having
money though did she have money at the
time of her arrest I don't know
I don't know but like I said everything
that I everything that I read said that
she made a lot of money right but I
don't know if she was like splashing in
a room maybe she just wasn't a real
extravagant person but she was just
greedy right she was just greedy okay
she just wasn't really living hand to
mouth no okay no no no
and I mean she could afford to like move
around whenever she wanted to and like
you know move to house and [__] like
that so she probably had a had a had a
[__] money stashed up I would imagine
a moving away fun and like I said
especially after they started after
um Margaret Waters got hanged which was
two years before Amelia Dyer got caught
I think
you know the actually the government
started like cracking down and like
looking well maybe we should regulate
this [__] look like look at this
[__] right here and so Amelia Dyer
and some of the other baby Farmers that
were doing the same [__] that she was
doing were like yeah we need to kind of
like keep this [__] on the download
because we're gonna get caught too and
they didn't want to get hanged either
but they but it almost seemed like she
like when she went to jail like when she
went to prison for six months
um for neglect
and that was even before she started
murdering murdering the babies that was
just when she was kind of like letting
them die or just like helping him along
a little bit
um she kind of I it almost seemed like
she vowed like after she got out she's
like oh I really don't want to go back
to jail so she was gonna try and go
legit like she went back to nursing and
stuff like that but then it seemed like
she couldn't resist it
that's what I mean and I don't think and
I don't think it was necessarily just
the money yeah and that was another
thing that a lot of the documentaries
brought up they're like it's a lot
easier work than nursing that's for sure
and you had to have a boss when you're
nursing right you know when she's
killing babies she's a [__] captain
of her own ship she didn't have to
listen to anybody
yeah she just takes him baby and like I
said it's easy she doesn't really have
to do anything right other than store
the baby until it does yeah and or or
other than like you know make up all
these stories to the parents like about
where the baby went and all this other
kind of stuff but other than that like
it's a lot easier than nursing
especially back then
so because of the amount of
um you know the period of time that she
was doing this
um the amount of letters the amount of
parents that were looking for their kids
the amount of you know all the stuff
that they found in her house and stuff
there have been estimates even though
she was technically only hanged for
um I believe three murders
because of the three like three babies
that they found in the Thames
um that they knew were hers uh they
speculate that operating as she did
conservative estimate probably between
four and five hundred babies probably
that she killed
um but yeah probably twice that yeah and
it may be more
um yeah they said if she was quicker
than that because everybody that was
witness to everybody that lived near her
like wherever she lived and stuff like
that said there was babies in and out of
there all the time and actually and
actually yeah it was it was off and on
Luke and the thing about it too was that
Granny the women that was living with
her she didn't know what was going on at
first but she kept thinking I mean she
wasn't super bright but I mean she was
like all these baby and she loved babies
like she wasn't like evil or anything so
it's like so all she's like all these
babies to come in and then she's like
the next day they'd be gone and like she
didn't really know what happened to them
and after a while she started getting
suspicious so she went and reported
Amelia also like after a while because
she's like there's got to be something
going on because I don't know where the
[__] all these babies are going so she
could she could she'd get rid of both of
them she would get rid of a lot of them
in one day huh yeah sometimes she would
just go pick the she would go like on
the train to wherever the mother was and
pick the baby up and take you know get
the box of clothes and the money then
she would come back home and then pretty
much she would immediately kill the baby
damn it seemed like
most of the time yeah didn't want that
trouble yeah because like I said why why
spend money like feeding the baby or
yeah it's a waste of money or listening
to or listening to baby crying or
whatever when you could just like
[__] strangle him and just yeah
probably be solved you know what I mean
so uh so yeah
um
so Amelia gets arrested on uh April 4th
of that year and she gets charged with
murder now as I said her daughter uh
Polly and her son-in-law whose name is
Arthur Palmer were charged alongside of
her as accessories
but this and this is crazy to me because
this is a woman who has killed perhaps
four to five hundred babies
but she did not want her daughter and
son-in-law to go to prison
so because she was afraid that they
would get in trouble too she basically
just confessed to the whole thing and
said yeah I did it all myself they
didn't do anything
so she got so they got off
I don't know how much they knew I'm just
I suspect they probably knew what was
going on uh because they were in and out
of the house but she was out of it
helped they yeah they might have and but
she was adamant that they'd not get in
trouble
um so she confessed to everything
like her she broke like these big like
[__] notebooks and notebooks full of
confession
um you know what I mean so uh so yeah
and uh basically
they um I mean they didn't really find
any evidence that her daughter and
son-in-law had known anything about it
but I don't know they were kind of in
and out so I suspect they probably did
so did she explained in her notebooks
how she progressed and went through this
and what she was thinking sort like I
said I've read some of it
um she's not real I don't want to say
she's not articulate but I mean she
can't spell that's for one thing but um
but she does seem to know that what she
did was horrible
but
I don't know it almost seems like she
got into a situation where it just kept
escalating and escalating
and
at every stage I don't know it just
seemed like that frog and boiling water
thing yeah you know what I mean where it
just seemed like she kind of got started
doing it it was like yeah and had to
have re had every intention at first of
like taking these babies and then she's
like oh man these babies are like so
noisy and you have to feed them and it
costs money and all this other stuff and
then she's like maybe it is better to
just kind of like give them wadding them
and oh no it died you know what I mean
and then she's just kind of like well
let's just hasten this along you know
what I mean so I think at every stage
she was just kind of like it was like
practical concerns but like I said I
think in the end I think she was
starting to get off it became routine
and then she started to like it yeah I
think that's exactly what happened
so um so in May of 1896
um she showed up at the Old Bailey and
she actually pleaded guilty to only one
murder
uh Doris Martin who is um you know
evelina's baby
now uh so basically they it came out
later like I said that she'd almost been
caught like lots of times because a lot
of people were suspicious about what she
was doing how could you not be because
she did move around a lot and she had
like different aliases and [__] like
that but I mean if you were in a place
for any length of time like your
neighbors would notice like all of these
babies coming in and out it's like hey
where'd that one go and it's like yeah
she always had excuses like oh we
adopted them out because that's what
they're supposed to be doing but a lot
of people were suspicious it wasn't just
granny it was like some other people
that were suspicious too but they
couldn't prove anything you know what I
mean
um so yeah now the only thing I mean
what could she say pretty much uh the
only defense she offered was Insanity
which she did kind of have a leg to
stand on because she had been in and out
of bental asylums however uh most modern
researchers believe that although she
was for sure a laudnam addict big time
um and maybe had some history of mental
illness in her family and maybe she had
like legit like tried to commit suicide
a couple times and everything like that
but they think that because she had a
lot of experience with mental illness
being a nurse in an asylum and like
having gone through her mother's uh
illness and stuff like that that she
knew how to fake it essentially because
it did seem
cool you know it seemed kind of
convenient that whenever she was about
to get caught or she thought she was
going to get in trouble she would all of
a sudden have an episode and they would
put her in an asylum for a while and
then kind of until like the heat blew
over you know what I mean so a lot of
people thought that was suspicious so I
don't really think anyone bought it and
I think that like people did
come in and like assess her and stuff
like you know psychologist assessor and
stuff like that they're like nah she
knew what she was doing she's not crazy
so uh so yeah but that was like pretty
much the only thing she could say I mean
really now this is crazy so if Mary
piercy's jury only took 52 minutes to
convict her
Amelia Dyer's jury took only four and a
half minutes
here don't die yeah yeah
um so yeah so while she was in there
like I said she wrote this like five
notebooks full of like [__] her
confession or whatever
um and on the night before she was
executed uh you know the prison chaplain
comes in and said do you have anything
to confess and she gave him the books
and said is this enough you know what I
mean so
um now interestingly what okay this is
crazy too so she got executed right
um in uh on June 10th 1896. because like
I said they didn't [__] around back then
I think it was just three weeks between
her getting the death sentence and her
swinging from a rope they just got it
over with man you didn't want to sit
around prison waiting for that [__] yeah
they basically uh food sucked might as
well just [__] go yeah
um interestingly not too long after she
was killed
um maybe it was was it a year or two
year or something like that I can't
remember exactly but there was a an
incident at a train station where a baby
was left in a box like on the train
tracks like left there to die
um you know but thankfully
um people like the porters at the real
like found the baby like before and they
saved the baby
and when they found out who had left the
baby guess who it was it was Polly it
was Amelia's daughter
so carrying on the family business I see
like leaving babies out to die and [__]
like that that's really nice but yeah I
think that was a couple years ago you
want to try to get rid of her own
daughter
no no no oh what was it no Polly
Amelia's daughter yeah who was grown she
was an adult it wasn't her daughter
no she just it was a random ass baby she
just like left the baby in a box like at
a [__] on a [__] train track or
some [__] like that so they surprised
that oh well she's doing the same [__]
yeah I'm telling you man they were
helping I think they were probably
hoping she left her own baby there no I
don't think it was her it was just a
random ass baby
um so yeah now after
Amelia Dyer
um obviously it took a couple of years
but a lot of the laws were changed uh by
the way Amelia Dyer is also known as the
ogres of reading yeah which uh yeah a
little bit but yeah there's even like a
song about her and [__] like that like
an old ballad or whatever so um but what
they did after her case because it was
like such a huge [__] scandal
and like I said the Margaret Waters case
had been a couple years before too so
people the public was kind of like there
was a huge outcry so basically they
started regulating [__] more like they
made adoption laws much stricter
um and they still allowed baby Farms but
they had like more oversight like they
had you know people coming in and
checking on them and things like that
because it you know the whole system
prior to that you didn't need a license
you didn't there was no regulation there
was no oversight there was nobody
checking on any of that [__] but these
were low value that's what I mean so it
was just like so the whole system was
just like ripe for exploitation and
um but after that like after the
magnitude of what had happened like kind
of dawned on everybody they're like yeah
we really need to like [__] yeah I'd
imagine British Society was shocked they
were they were horrified kill [__]
thousand kids they were horrified yeah
so uh so yeah I didn't understand
[__] the magnitude
I mean I don't understand the magnitude
that is [__] crazy well I can imagine
it well like I see how it happens
especially back then but it's still like
horrifying to think that you actually
like probably killed like 400 [__]
babies yeah that's [__] crazy to me
and this like I said this [__] bummed
me out but oh [__] like this
could be happening for all we know in
real [__] poor neighborhoods in
pretty poor countries you know what I
mean if I can wear free of Bangladesh
somewhere in a poor neighboring
Bangladesh or somewhere in India you you
might have a situation where unwed
mothers are not allowed and they just
throw the baby away you know that might
actually exist still yeah probably see
that that was the stage that England was
in at that time you know what I mean
which is what was funny is 1800s
late 1800s uh England would it was kind
of like one of the leaders of the world
yeah so
we're sitting here talking about how bad
it was that was like one of the best
places in the world to live yeah so
everywhere else was like worse than
[__] terrible well America was good
too it was more country living in most
of it but you had to fight to make it
out there you're in Indian Territory and
there may those Indians may or may not
be friendly where you're living or uh
well late 1800s a lot of that was over
by that time but
the uh you know
America had its own problems too it's
just best thing about America compared
to England of the late 1800s is
it tended to be better food more fresh
water less population density
like uh the South South was uh in the
1800s pretty rich compared to a lot of
places in Europe and even the poor
people ate well because it was
subsistence farming every house grew
their own [__]
even to this day food is just like a
religion in the south
it's like that in Mexico where you go
south the more independent the people
are the more they [__] Farm their own
lands and [__] the more food is a
[__] religion
yeah you couldn't do that in the city
yeah you can't do that in the city so
England you know England was like it
only in the country and I think we're
only rich people lived in the country in
England
well I mean if you were poor you kind of
had to live in the city yeah that's
where the work yes
it's kind of you know
um but yeah so much like the Mary Piercy
case where people have speculated that
she is a suspect for Jack River Jill the
Ripper if you prefer Amelia Dyer has
also been put forward
as a suspect for Jack the Ripper
although like I said that one seems like
even more of a reach because the ammo is
completely completely different
um because as I mentioned
she didn't
um you know she's much more like an
angel of death style killer
um which we did a show about a while
back we which is usually what women
killers are that's usually if they kill
a lot of people that's usually what they
do they kill babies or they kill elderly
people or they poison people in
hospitals or [__] like that
um you know they do [__] like this
so it she's not really killing people in
the same manner as Jack the Ripper was
Mary Piercy like I said yeah she slashed
that woman's throat and beat the [__]
out of her like with a fireplace poker
which like I said is more in line with
what Jack the Ripper did but not really
the same motive I feel like so I don't
really feel and I don't even know how I
feel about that whole Jack the Ripper
was a woman thing no I just I don't buy
it like and and like I said it's not a
new Theory like people were talking
about that like even back in the early
20th century like late 19th century
early 20th century like people were
throwing that idea around but
like I you know I don't um no I don't
see it I don't I don't see it that like
I said that seems like a very that was a
man's crime that is a very bad a very
badly it took off it took uh strength to
do a lot of the [__] that was done uh in
the river case and uh the attacks were
sexual yeah he's removing sexual organs
and stuff it was the focus on faces
breasts and badges a lot of it yeah and
so that was the sexual thing it was it
was a man doing that yeah
oh [__] psycho whereas these two
um you know there wasn't the neither of
these crimes had a sexual motive
obviously
um the first crime that seemed like more
like a crime of passion like a jealousy
type of crime and the second one was
practical yeah reasons like monetary
gain that went into maybe yeah getting
off on the Ripper cases were
premeditated stalking he was an
organized killer that's how he got in
and out of there
yeah he was wearing a disguise or
something and like I said he wasn't
noticed really like he didn't stick out
all that much so he was walking around
with the tools that he needed and
wearing what he had to wear in order to
get in and out of there without noticed
and he may have had Transportation you
don't know yeah and I don't know if
we'll ever know which is kind of a
bummer because it was such a long time
transportation in those days would have
been a carriage
and I don't know maybe a carriage would
have cost too much to attract too much
tension he probably just walked
one of the reasons there was something
about him that didn't attract attention
and I had just forgotten about this
until we were just talking about it one
of the reasons that um and I think this
was a couple years ago that this
happened but there was kind of a big
um like a big public thing because you
know how they they did um DNA testing on
the stamps that were on the Jack the
Ripper letters yeah and the DNA on there
they're pretty sure that that was a
woman's DNA but that doesn't necessarily
mean that the killer put like licked the
stamp and also I mean that was the
killer that wrote those letters right
the one that said the from Hell letter
with the piece of kidney in it they
never verified that was a human kidney
that might have been something bought
from a [__] butcher shop it might
have been a [__] sheep's kidney
well that's the thing I don't think
there was any wave of determining not
back then back then and if it was just a
piece of kidney it probably wouldn't the
whole kidney it was just like that's a
piece of kidney but it's something that
I got at a butcher shop because they had
hoax letters happening and people yeah
all the time that's not new either yeah
every time there was like a crime that
was like roll sorted or it was in the
papers you'd have all kind of crazy
people being like yeah I did that [__]
they're like written yeah yeah same same
as now there's a good there's a good
chance that the Ripper never even
contacted the police he was a Gary
Ridgeway type guy who didn't want he was
just keeping his [__] private he wanted
the bodies to be found he wanted to be
famous he was probably a guy like Ray
like Charles Raider or I would say uh
Raider
for BTK he's probably like a BTK
kind of a large
I thought I thought it was good is it
back uh no it's orange
okay
okay it says it reconnected let's see if
it's green
do green I don't know I can't see it the
thing's in the way
okay now it's green it's green okay
because when the thing pops up I can't
see yeah okay yeah I'm back I'm back
over here too yeah I was just saying
that
a lot of the theories about the Ripper
just fanciful theories the chances are
he's just some country guy who had good
skills and uh you know May
and uh was intelligent and uh didn't
like women and especially he didn't like
hell hag prostitutes and uh he was taken
out Vengeance on him I think it looked
like Vengeance crimes he hated them
it's good that's how bracia said I think
Jack the Ripper was misogynist yeah big
time because he defaced him so badly he
wasn't just a pervert he [__] hated
him
yeah like you said he just he cut their
faces out he cut out all their sexual
organs and [__] like that so obviously
some you know he may have gotten some
kind of STD from prostitutes and uh
maybe he was he might have had syphilis
it was dying you don't know
and uh said [__] it I'm going to take
these up they did it to me I'm gonna
take them out
might have something like that I mean
that does sound like more that sounds
like yeah he hated him so and he may
have known them too that's another thing
maybe
or maybe not
could have just been random
he had a type that he looked for old hag
prostitutes that's mostly who they were
I don't think that one was a hag
a couple of them weren't but they tended
to be just Hags well they were a little
older well some of them weren't that old
but they were like alcoholics and stuff
so they look kind of rough yeah you see
photographs of you like look like
they're in their 70s
yeah like a bad 70s they got hot [__]
women in their 70s
go [__] look at go look at [__]
Cassandra Peterson what a girl plays
Elvira
let's see 75 or something 74. that
woman's [__] gorgeous they got you
you can be old and be a good looking but
those good women just look like [__]
hags well like I said they had a rough
life yeah got him some slack yeah and
they got murdered in like the worst way
yeah well yeah if you go to like a Jack
the Ripper site they're like and look at
like the suspect thing there's like 40
bajillion [__] suspects yeah you
can't even read through all this nah he
was just some kind of guy if you saw him
you go yeah that's him but he's probably
kind of unassuming in the way Dennis
Raider was kind of unassuming
yeah you wouldn't suspect because he
just looked like a nobody you know yeah
or a functionary like he belonged there
just walking around
you know dog catcher yeah
thank you very much Mrs Evans already
party which is one of my favorite screen
names yeah this show is sad but
fascinating thanks for keeping me
entertained while I do chores yeah it's
like I'm not I was I know this is [__]
up but it's like I was kind of excited
to do this show because I've been
wanting to do a show but Amelia dire for
like a really long time but then like
the more documentaries I watched it but
I'm like wow this is like really
depressing and I don't usually get like
that but I don't know for some reason
this one like really bumped me out I
guess because I've been watching like
[__] about it for three days and
they did um if you've ever seen the
British show murder Maps which is really
really good they talk about like a lot
of Victorian crime and stuff like that
they did a really good show about this
one
but uh but yes there's a couple good
like documentaries about it but murder
Maps was the best one all right so I
guess we're gonna wrap it up because
it's getting late it's past 10 o'clock
and I gotta get up real early tomorrow
that's usual weekend will be here soon I
know at least it's Thursday Friday we'll
be here soon you come home and work and
then you would chill out and then you
know yeah then I can chill out yeah yeah
[Laughter]
oh [__] it might be this Friday now but
I'm thinking about it I mean you have to
look it up because I just saw something
about it and I was just kind of like oh
[__] that might be this Friday again
yeah so yeah so we might and I don't
think we went to the last one did we
didn't we yeah okay we missed it so we
should probably go to this yeah all
right so we're gonna wrap it up for the
evening
hopefully you guys enjoyed the show even
though it was a super depressing topic
but it was interesting anyway so
hopefully you guys found it interesting
anymore well that we know of yeah
not at that scale not not in the western
world and these these [__] are both
dead so yeah you know that's that's
something
uh so yeah so we will be back Friday
night as usual for the side track show
so hopefully you guys can join us for
that and hopefully we'll see you all
then and have a good rest of your night
you guys